ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव
जस्ट चेकिंग पहले आ गया मैं आज लाइव तो आप
सबके लिए
इन द एसओसी
क्लास सेवन
ओके
तो आई थिंक गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग
एवरीबॉडी।
नमस्ते। नमस्ते।
अ वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू। नमस्ते टू
ऑल ऑफ यू।
चलिए मैं एक बार बता दीजिए मुझे एक बार
जल्दी से। मेरी ऑडियो बिल्कुल क्लियर आ
रही है। वीडियो क्लियर आ रही है। सब कुछ
सही है। सभी को आ जाने देते हैं एक बार।
फर्स्ट लेट एवरीबडी जॉइ।
तो पहले सबको आ जाने देते हैं।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
गुड इवनिंग
हट्स ऑफ टू यू सर सर
इतना बिजी होने के बावजूद भी लाइव आ रहे
हो। बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल मैंने बोला
ही था कि आप लाइव आया करो कमेंट्स कर दिया
करो 250 हर वीडियो के ऊपर एंड आई एम देयर
एंड आई एम देयर।
बस मैं इतना ही बोलूंगा।
गुड इवनिंग।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू। वेरी
वेरीरी गुड इवनिंग गाइस। सभी को
गुड इवनिंग। लुकिंग एनर्जेटिक एनर्जेटिक
देन प्रीवियस क्लास। एनर्जेटिक तो होगा ना
भाई। तुम लोग आओगे तो मैं एनर्जेटिक फील
करूंगा। अभी क्या काफी कम लोग आए हैं तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। एनर्जी डाउन हो जाएगी
फिर थोड़ी देर बाद। सिंपल सी बात है। सो
देयर आर आई हो आई थिंक कि सिर्फ कितने लोग
हैं अभी फिलहाल के लिए? 54 पीपल आर देयर।
बताओ यह हाल है तुम लोगों की। तो एनर्जी
डाउन कैसे नहीं होगी? आप भी बताओ ना। 51
पीपल आर देयर। सो लेट्स लेट एवरीबॉडी जॉइ।
सबको पहले जॉइ करने देते हैं। देन ओनली वी
विल स्टार्ट द सेशन। ठीक है? सब अभी 100
प्लस तो होंगे तभी हम सेशन स्टार्ट
करेंगे। अदरवाइज़ वी विल नॉट स्टार्ट द
सेशन। सीधी-सीधी बात है। मैं सेशन कैंसिल
कर दूंगा। इसका रीजन सिंपल सा है। मैं
आपको बता देता हूं। ठीक है? यह वीडियो कुछ
टाइम के लिए रहेगी भी। अगर सेशन कैंसिल भी
हो जाती है तब भी।
सिंपल सा रीज़न है। मैं एक बहुत ही क्लोज
चाइल्डहुड फ्रेंड के वेडिंग में हॉलिडे पे
था। एंड क्योंकि अगर मैं हॉलिडज़ को ऐसे
एंजॉय करता तो मुझे लगता है कि मैं दो-तीन
दिन और फ्री नहीं हो पाता। एंड फिर क्या
होता कि आपकी सेशन बहुत ज्यादा डिले हो
जाती। और क्योंकि आपने 250 प्लस कमेंट्स
ऑलरेडी कर दिए थे और मैंने बोला था कि 250
कमेंट्स जैसे ही आप करेंगे आई विल ब्रिंग
द सेशन। तो उसके अकॉर्डिंग मुझे सेशन लाना
था।
तो अगर मैं बहाने नहीं कर सकता एंड आई एम
देयर कि मैं एक ऐसी इंपॉर्टेंट फंक्शन को
साइडलाइन कर सकता हूं।
भले 2 घंटे के लिए करूं। तो आप क्यों नहीं
कर सकते? मुझे यह नहीं समझ में आ रहा जब
आपको फ्री में चीजें मिल रही हैं। दैट्स
व्हाई पीपल कीप सेइंग कि फ्री को चीज फ्री
की चीजों की वैल्यू नहीं है। लोगों का यही
कहना है। सभी लोग बोलते हैं सभी
एंटरप्रेन्योर हैं। सभी फाउंडर्स हो गए
हैं या एटक अ कंपनीज़ जो होती हैं या या यू
कैन से कि जो ट्रेनर्स होते हैं वो उनका
मानना यही है। इवन प्रोफेशनल्स का मानना
है कि फ्री की चीजों को कोई वैल्यू नहीं
देता। जनरली कोई नहीं का मतलब है कि यहां
पर अभी हमारे पास 500 होने वाले हैं
डिफ्रॉनिक्स। उसमें से अगर आप 500 लोग भी
नहीं आ पा रहे हैं। 500 छोड़ो यार मैं तो
100 की बात कर रहा था। 100 200 की बात वो
भी अगर नहीं आ पा रहे इसका मतलब है कि
आपको आप में से जितने भी लोग हैं जो एसओसी
के लिए काफी एक्साइटेड रह रहे थे।
आई डोंट थिंक कि यू आर प्र यू आर एक्चुअली
प्रिपेयरिंग फॉर इट। एंड आई डोंट थिंक कि
यू एक्चुअली वांट
जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग। आप लोगों को वही चाहिए
जो दूसरे इंस्टीट्यूट्स वाले आपको बेवकूफ
पागल बना देते हैं। एंड आपसे पैसे लूट
लेते हैं। सर्टिफिकेट के नाम पे आपको आपका
काटा जाता है। एंड आपसे हजारों लाखों रुपए
चार्ज किए जाते हैं। यू ओनली नीड दैट टाइप
ऑफ इंस्टीटश जहां आपको पैसे देने हैं।
पैसे देके चाहे वो हम खुद क्यों ना हो।
चाहे हम खुद क्यों ना हो वो अलग बात है।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स में कभी किसी का काटा नहीं
जाता। इवन फॉर पे ट्रेनिंग। किसी को किसी
का ऐसे नहीं उठाया जाता फायदा कि हां भाई
चलो आ जाओ पैसे दे दो ये हो जाएगा वो हो
जाएगा। गलत प्रॉमिससेस नहीं की जाती। बट
मैक्सिमम इंस्टट्यूट्स डज़ दिस। राइट? आप
सबको भी पता है। कई कई लोगों को पता होगा।
तो मेरा यह मानना है कि अगर आप 100 भी
यहां पर नहीं है प्रेजेंट
सेशन में तो मेरा कोई भी मोटिव नहीं है
सेशन लेने का। मैं तो कैंसिल कर सकता हूं।
मेरे लिए कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है। इट्स जस्ट
अ स्नैप ऑफ़ फिंगर एंड मैं जाऊंगा एंड बटन
एंड स्ट्रीम करूंगा एंड खत्म। कहानी खत्म।
बट इसमें लॉस एक्चुअली किसका है? मेरा लॉस
बस इसका इतना ही है ना कि व्यूज नहीं
आएंगे। मतलब इस वीडियो पे व्यू नहीं आएगा
पर्टिकुलर वीडियो पे ऐसे करके जो भी है
व्हाटएवर। इसमें एक्चुअल लॉस किसका ये
बताइए मुझे आप खुद सोचिए कि एक्चुअल लॉस
आपका है कि नहीं है। अगर मैं ऐसी चीजों
में निकाल के टाइम अगर आपके पास आया हूं
सेशन लेने तो आपके आपकी ये
सिर्फ एक आपका एक रिस्पांसिबिलिटी बनता है
कि यू हैव टू अटेंड द सेशन।
69 पीपल आर देयर ओनली। 70 पीपल आर देयर।
ठीक है? कोई लेट नाइट स्टार्ट करने से लोग
नहीं आते। यह गलतफहमी है और यह गलत बातें
हैं। ये इसको छोड़ दो। दिस इज़ जस्ट अ
मिसकंसेप्शन कि नेट लाइट क्लास स्टार्ट
करेंगे तो लोग आएंगे। ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं
होता है। आई हैव ट्राइड एवरीथिंग। आई हैव
सो सीन एवरीथिंग। ठीक है?
कुछ लोग हैं जो रेगुलर होते हैं
उनकी बात मैं बिल्कुल नहीं करता। मैं उनको
कुछ भी नहीं बोलता। जो रेगुलर होते हैं,
मैं उनको स्कॉल नहीं कर रहा। मैं उनको
नहीं बोल रहा। बट जो लोग इसको टेकन फॉर
ग्रांटेड ले रहे हैं इस ट्रेनिंग को। मैं
आपको गारंटी देता हूं कि मैं उस टाइप का
बंदा हूं, उस टाइप का इंसान हूं।
कि व्यूज आए इसलिए मैं ट्रेनिंग को
कंटिन्यू करूं। ऐसा कभी नहीं होता है। आप
इंटरेस्ट दिखाएंगे तभी ट्रेनिंग होगी नहीं
तो नहीं होगी। सीधी सी बात है ट्रेनिंग तब
तक नहीं होगी। और आज मुझे सिर्फ 66 ओनली
66 पीपल आर देयर।
ठीक है? आप मुझे सुपर चैट मत करो। 20 40
100 का। यू डोंट आई डोंट नीड योर सुपर
चैट। आई नीड योर प्रेजेंस। सिंपल सी बात
है। अब मैं एक मैसेज कर रहा हूं ग्रुप
में। अगर उनको थोड़ी भी लगे कि हां
उनको थोड़ी भी लगे कि
आनी चाहिए तो दे शुड कम अदरवाइज आई विल
सिंपली कैंसिल द सेशन मैं बस इतना ही
बोलूंगा बाकी आप लोग समझिएगा उसके बाद का
यू आर ओनली रिस्पांसिबल गाइस ओनली यू गाइस
आर रेस्पोंसिबल बस इतना आप समझ के चलिए
अगर कोई भी सेशन कैंसिल होती है या कुछ भी
होता है ओनली यू गाइस आर रिस्पांसिबल
फालतू की ट्रेनिंग्स लेनी है आपको।
फालतू की ट्रेनिंग्स लेनी है।
एंड पैसे फालतू के खर्च करने हैं।
बट
रियल ट्रेनिंग जब चाहिए तब आपको उस टाइम
दिक्कत आ जाती है। मैं सीधी-सीधी बात आपको
बता रहा हूं। क्लियर कट बता रहा हूं। मेरे
को ना तो किसी का डर है ना तो किसी की ऐसी
कोई
मेरी मजबूरी है कि मैं आपको क्लासेस
कराऊंगा। मैं आपके लिए क्लासेस लेकर आया
हूं और आपके लिए करा रहा था। अगर आपको ही
करने का मन नहीं है तो सीधा-सीधा बताइए अ
मैसेज में यहां पे कि आपको क्लास नहीं
करनी है एंड आई विल डिस्कंटिन्यू दी दिस
सीरीज। क्योंकि जब तक 100 प्लस नहीं
होंगे, आई विल नेवर स्टार्ट द सेशन। सीधी
सी बात है। पहले तो 100 प्लस श्योरली
चाहिए। और अगर 100 प्लस किसी भी सेशन में
नहीं होंगे, आई विल डिस्कंटिन्यू द सेशन।
आई विल नॉट टेक दैट सेशन। क्योंकि आपको
टेकन फॉर ग्रांटेड आप ले रहे हो। आपको मजा
आपको मजाक लग रहा है तो आई विल नॉट
कंटिन्यू दिस मजाक। सिंपल सा फंडा है। अभी
भी 104 लोग हैं अभी फिलहाल।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग।
नहीं आप लोगों को करना है क्लास बट आप
लोगों को आई डोंट थिंक कि आप सीरियसली ले
रहे हैं इस सेशंस को। कोई नहीं कराएगा यार
ऐसे यार। आप समझते क्यों नहीं हो? मुझे
समझ नहीं आ रहा।
ओके
सात लोगों को लगा होगा ना बट बट यहां पे
तो नोटिफिकेशंस जाते हैं ब्रदर
नोटिफिकेशंस जाते हैं ना
चलिए
तो यहां पे 100 प्लस लोग आ चुके हैं देयर
आर 100 प्लस प्लस पीपल नाउ नाउ वी विल
स्टार्ट द सेशन एस पर माय प्रॉमिस
डेफिनेटली आई विल स्टार्ट द सेशन। मैं
आपको पहले ही बता चुका हूं कि मैं एक
फ्रेंड के वेडिंग में बिजी हूं काफी
ज्यादा फिर भी मैं आपकी सेशन ले रहा हूं।
तो थोड़ी उसकी सिंसियरनेस को समझिए। इफ आई
एम देयर फॉर यू, देन यू शुड बी देयर फॉर
मी। राइट?
एम आई राइट?
मुझे बताइए कि मैं अगर आप बताइए ना मुझे
आपके चाइल्डहुड फ्रेंड से के वेडिंग से
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट कुछ हो सकता है? अगर
मैं नेगेटिव सेंस में ना बात करूं पॉजिटिव
में हैप्पी हैप्पी एनवायरमेंट की बात करूं
तो एक चाइल्डहुड फ्रेंड के वेडिंग से
ज्यादा कुछ हो सकता है क्या? मुझे नहीं
लगता कुछ हो सकता है। अगर आपके भी दोस्त
की शादी होगी कहीं आपको इनवाइट इनवाइट
किया जाएगा इनविटेशंस होंगी या कुछ ऐसा
क्लोज रिलेटिव्स के होंगे तो आप जाएंगे
ना? बिल्कुल जाना चाहेंगे।
तो फिर मैं यहां पर क्या कर रहा हूं मैं
आपके लिए? मैं आपके लिए इसलिए आया हूं
क्योंकि आप 100 प्लस भी नहीं आए। मैं यहीं
पर रिक्वेस्ट करना करूं मैं आपके सामने
हमेशा कि आ जाओ आ जाओ आ जाओ। आई डोंट थिंक
इट अ दैट्स ग्रेट। तो मैं यहां रिक्वेस्ट
करनी आपके लिए आपके आपसे रिक्वेस्ट करने
नहीं आता हूं। मैं यहां पे आपको कुछ चीजें
डिलीवर कर रहा हूं। कुछ स्किल्स प्रोवाइड
कर रहा हूं। यू नो मैं आपके बेनिफिट के
लिए कर रहा हूं। मेरे बेनिफिट का कुछ नहीं
है। याद रखिएगा आप चीज। तो यू एक्चुअली
नीड मी। आई डोंट नीड यू एक्चुअली रियल
फैक्ट है आपको अच्छा ना लगे बुरा लगे आई
डोंट केयर बट एक्चुअली यू नीड मी आपके
स्किल्स के लिए मेरे टाइम कोई था नहीं यार
कोई बताने वाला नहीं कोई समझाने वाला नहीं
आपके समय इतनी चीजें दे रहे हैं हम फिर भी
आपको मजा नहीं आ रहा
सिंपल सा बात है सो आई एम वेरी वेरीरी
डिसपॉइंटंटेड टुडे डिसपॉइंटेड फील हो रहा
है बट स्टिल आज का सेशन मैं अभी स्टार्ट
तो कर देता हूं बट मैं नेक्स्ट सेशन नहीं
लूंगा अगर आप लोग नहीं आएंगे तो मैं सिंपल
सा फंडा बता रहा हूं। आई विल नॉट टेक द
नेक्स्ट सेशन। मैं चार्जर लेकर आता हूं।
आई थिंक लैपटॉप डिस्चार्ज होगा। सो जस्ट
वेट।
ओके सो
लेट मी कनेक्ट द
चार्जर फर्स्ट
ओके
पहली बात तो यार आपको ना पहली बात तो इतना
बोलने वाला कोई नहीं मिलता है। इतना कोई
बोलेगा नहीं आपको कोई भी चीज के लिए। कोई
कोई किसी को कोई मतलब नहीं होता है। बट
स्टिल अगर कोई बोल रहा है तो उसकी थोड़ी
रिस्पेक्ट करो। उसको थोड़ा सिंसियरली लो।
मैं बता रहा हूं। कोई नहीं कराएगा इससे।
सिंपल सा बात है। ठीक है?
तो अगर आना है तो आओ। नहीं आना है सिंपल
सा बोल दो कि सर आई डोंट वांट टू
कंटिन्यू। सर ये सीरीज मजेदार नहीं है।
सीरीज हमें नहीं चाहिए। दैट्स इट। मैं
खत्म कर दूंगा। कौन सी बड़ी बात है? चलिए
अ स्टार्ट करते हैं। लेट्स स्टार्ट। है
ना?
[संगीत]
ओके।
थैंक यू नितीश झा फॉर शेयरिंग द कंटेंट्स।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। आई एप्रिशिएट।
आई रियली अप्रिशिएट।
चलिए। सो स्टार्ट करते हैं। स्टार्ट करने
के पहले मैं आपको पहले ही बता दे रहा हूं।
यह मेरी Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप यहां पर
आके मुझसे जुड़ सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। फॉलो कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? एंड
Lindin पे ही आप जाके dfonic सर्च करेंगे
ओनली। तो आपको डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
की Lindin पेज मिल जाएगी जो हमारी कंपनी
की Lindin पेज है। यहां आप आके इस पेज को
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। जहां पे आप हमारे
21,000 लगभग 21,000 डिफरोंस्टर्स के साथ
जुड़ेंगे और हमारी कंपनी के अपडेट्स आपको
मिलते रहेंगे। हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग
जो भी डिटेल्स हैं, जो भी चीजें हैं, वो
सब मिलती रहेंगी एंड यू विल बी कनेक्टेड
टू आवर कंपनीज़
पेज। यह हमारी Twitter यानी एक्स पेज है।
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी X.com डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी द हैंडल।
यू कैन कम एंड फॉलो हियर। इट विल बी अ
ग्रेट लर्निंग स्टफ
फॉर यू। आने वाले टाइम में यहां पे काफी
कुछ आने वाला है। जिसको आप जिसको आप देख
के आपको मजा आएगा। तो, आप प्लीज फॉलो जरूर
कर लीजिएगा। Twitter के इस प्रोफाइल को
एक्स के प्रोफाइल को। यह वेबसाइट है। यहां
हमारा नंबर है। किसी भी तरह का कोई
इंक्वायरी कुछ भी कुछ करना हो तो आप यहां
पे हमारे नंबर से कांटेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
दिस इज़ आवर डेफ़ोनिक्स Academy Instagram
हैंडल जहां पर आप आके इनफेटिव रील्स एंड
ऑल ये सब चीजें देख सकते हैं। एंड
रिसेंटली अभी एक यहां पे एक आर्टिकल में
बेसिकली न्यूज़पेपर वगैरह में भी मेरी कुछ
आर्टिकल पब्लिश हुई थी। तो आप इसको भी ये
सब यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं। सिंपल सा
फंडा है। दिस इज़ एंड द मोस्टेंट थिंग।
किसी भी हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी के एसओसी
के क्लास के लाइव में जाइएगा डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी पे। पहली चीज ये कि डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी को अगर आपने बिल्कुल नए हैं,
सब्सक्राइब नहीं करा है तो सब्सक्राइब
करके ऑल पे क्लिक कर दीजिएगा। फर्स्ट
थिंग। दूसरी चीज किसी भी एसओसी के क्लास
को ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
इसके सीधा डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा। एंड
यहां पे आपको दो लिंक्स मिलेंगी। एक ग्रुप
का लिंक मिलेगा। WhatsApp ग्रुप एसओसी का
दूसरा WhatsApp चैनल का मिलेगा जो कि
डिफरिस का WhatsApp चैनल है। एसओसी के
ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा। सारी एसओसी
से रिलेटेड रिसोर्सेज, सर्टिफिकेशन के
रिगार्डिंग डिटेल्स जो आने वाली हैं एंड
जो भी चीजें हैं सब आपको इसी ग्रुप में
मिलेंगी। एंड WhatsApp चैनल पे आपको हमारी
जितनी भी ट्रेनिंग्स, फ्री कोर्सेज,
ट्रेनिंग्स, सब सर्टिफिकेशंस सब या जो भी
चीजें हैं उसकी सबसे पहले अपडेट आपको
WhatsApp चैनल पे मिलती है। तो आप इसको भी
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। बस इतना आपको काम करना
है। आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट काम यही है। बाकी
हम सेशन की तरफ आगे की ओर बढ़ जाते हैं।
तो आज की सेशन जो है हम बहुत ही एक
इंपॉर्टेंट एंड इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक के साथ स्टार्ट करेंगे। कई लोग में
से आप लोगों को इस टॉपिक के बारे में पता
होगा। बट इस टॉपिक की डिटेल जो है ना वो
शायद आपको उतनी पता नहीं होगी जितना मैं
आपको आज समझाने वाला हूं। बताने वाला हूं।
मेरे पास आज लिमिटेड टाइम है बट स्टिल मैं
आपको काफी कुछ चीजें कवर करने वाला हूं।
काफी कुछ चीजें समझाने वाला हूं। उसको
ध्यान से देखिएगा। ध्यान से समझिएगा। एंड
मैं आपको बार-बार पहले भी बोल चुका हूं।
मैं आज फिर अगेन रिपीट कर रहा हूं कि
एसओसी की यह जो ट्रेनिंग है यह कोई नॉर्मल
एरागैरा ट्रेनिंग नहीं है जिसके लिए आप
YouTube पे आए हैं या जिस तरीके से आप
YouTube पे बहुत सारी शॉर्ट कोर्सेज अ वन
शॉट कोर्सेज या कुछ प्लेलिस्ट्स देखते हैं
जिसको आधा अधूरा छोड़ दिया जाता है या आधा
कुछ भी हल्काफुल्का करा के फिर बाद में
अलग चीजें लाई जाती हैं तो वैसा यह
ट्रेनिंग कोर्स नहीं है। ये एक अपने आप
में इन जॉब ओरिएंटेड जॉब रेडी फ्री एसओसी
एल वन
जो है एसओसी एल वन की ये फ्री ट्रेनिंग है
अबब्सोलुटली फ्री कोई पैसा आपसे नहीं लिया
जाएगा किसी भी पोजीशन पे किसी भी टाइम
फ्रेम पे एंड आप एक एसओसी एल1 की स्किल्स
गेन कर लेंगे जिसके बाद आप ट्रेनिंग के
बाद आप एलिजिबल होंगे एसओसी एल1 के
इंटरव्यूज के लिए इंटरव्यूज एंड ऑल इन
सबके अलग सेशन जो भी होंगे जो रेगुलर
होंगे उनको मिलेगा। अदरवाइज आई डोंट नो।
सिंपल। तो आज जो हम है टॉपिक कुछ स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं जिसमें एक सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
टॉपिक है फिशिंग एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। अब
आप सोच रहे होंगे कि सर आप एसओसी की क्लास
करा रहे हो। साइबर सिक्योरिटी के टॉपिक्स
क्यों डील कर रहे हो? पिछले बार भी आपने
मैलवेयर वगैरह के बारे में बताया था।
साइबर सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड कुछ लगता है
खास। एसओसी अगर आपको एक रियल एसओसी
एनालिस्ट बनना है तो यू वुड बी
गेनिंग द स्किल्स नॉलेज
360 डिग्री 360° आपको नॉलेज लेनी है। तभी
आप एक अच्छे एसओसी एनालिस्ट बन सकते हैं।
एसओसी का मतलब है
एसओसी एनालिस्ट का मतलब है सिक्योरिटी
ऑपरेशन सेंटर एनालिस्ट। इसका मतलब होता है
कि एक एसओसी एनवायरमेंट के अंदर आप एक
सिस्टम को, एक सर्वर को, एक कंप्यूटर को,
एक प्रिंटर को या किसी भी नेटवर्क
डिवाइसेस को कितने अलग-अलग तरह के अटैक्स
से बचा सकते हैं। एंड सेफगार्ड कर सकते
हैं। एंड उसको काउंटर मेजर करने के
अलग-अलग तरीके अप्लाई कर सकते हैं। अब जब
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग और फिशिंग जैसे अटैक्स
होते हैं तो इससे भी बचने का तरीका आपको
पता होना चाहिए या किस तरीके से आप इनको
टैकल कर सकते हैं। क्योंकि ये जो अटैक्स
है फिशिंग एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग ये अपने
आप में एक बहुत बड़ी लेवल की अटैक्स हैं।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का कोई भी सॉल्यूशन नहीं
है। काउंटर मेजर नहीं होता है। क्योंकि
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग किसी टेक्निकल
फॉल्ट की वजह से नहीं होती है।
किसी कोड की वजह से नहीं होती है। यह इस
टाइप के अटैक्स हैं जो किसी फिशिंग या
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का ही पार्ट है। फिशिंग
जो किसी कोड की वजह से अटैक नहीं किए
जाएंगे। डेवलपर की गलती की वजह से अटैक
नहीं किए जाएंगे बल्कि आपकी गलती और आपकी
प्रॉब्लम्स, आपकी मिस्टेक्स की वजह से यह
अटैक्स पॉसिबल हो पाते हैं।
तो, हम इन दोनों के बारे में थोड़ा डिटेल
समझेंगे और मैंने हमेशा बोला है कि एसओसी
की जब आप सेशंस ले रहे हैं, व्हनेवर यू आर
टेकिंग द एसओसी सेशन।
ठीक है? व्हनेवर
कौन है भाई?
चल
निकल लो भाई यार ऐसेसे लोगों को पता नहीं
कहां से आ जाते हैं यार बेवकूफ लोग निकल
गए ये बेचारे
चलिए
थैंक यू दैनिश थैंक यू थैंक यू वेरी मच
चलो 119 लोग 115 लोग के ऊपर हैं यहां पे
जो जॉइ है अच्छा लग रहा है इट्स गुड अगर
आप जॉइ हैं इट्स गुड अच्छा लगता है
सिंपल
चलिए
अह यू आर ना एक्साइटेड हां गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गाइस। गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग अ वेरी वेरीरी गुड
इवनिंग। ओके गाइस। सो
यहां पे सबसे पहले हम बात करेंगे व्हाट इज़
फिशिंग की। फिशिंग एग्जैक्टली क्या होता
है? सबसे पहले हम इसके बारे में बात
करेंगे। एंड देन हम फिशिंग को किस तरीके
से एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं? देयर आर व्हाटएवर
वेज़ एंड देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स। वो हम सब
देखेंगे। फिशिंग इज अ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक वेयर अटैकर्स ट्रिक यूज़र्स इनू
रिवलिंग क्रेडेंशियल्स, क्लिकिंग मलेशियस
लिंक्स, डाउनलोडिंग मैल्वेस, ट्रांसफरिंग
मनी, इंस्टॉलिंग रिमोट एक्सेस टूल्स
ये सारी चीजें फिशिंग में होती है। अब ये
जो टॉपिक्स है, यह इतनी इंपॉर्टेंट है
आपके लिए कि अगर आप जॉब रेडी टाइप
ट्रेनिंग कर रहे हैं कोई एसओसी के। देखो
नॉर्मल एरागरा ट्रेनिंग कर रहे हैं, तो तब
तो ये जरूरत भी शायद नहीं होगी। जॉब रेडी
की अगर मैं बात कर रहा हूं अगर वो
ट्रेनिंग कर रहे हो तो एक-एक छोटी-छोटी
चीजें छोटी-छोटी टॉपिक्स इन छोटी-छोटी जो
कांसेप्ट्स हैं
वो आपके लिए उतनी ही इंपॉर्टेंट है। मैं
इतना ही बोलूंगा आपसे। दैट्स इट। फिशिंग
का मतलब है एक ऐसा यह सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का
ही एक पार्ट है। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के अंदर
फिशिंग को हम देखते हैं। तो यहां पे मैं
फिशिंग की पहले बात कर रहा हूं क्योंकि
फिशिंग को सोशल इंजीनियरिंग से हम बाद में
कनेक्ट करेंगे। तो फिशिंग का मतलब सिंपल
है कि एक ऐसा अटैक, एक ऐसा सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक आई वुड से एक एक ऐसा
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक
जहां पे अटैकर यूज़र्स को क्या ट्रिक करता
है? क्रेडेंशियल्स रिवील करने में मतलब
कोई भी सेंसिटिव डाटा रिवील करने में जैसे
यूजर्स यूजरनेम हो गया, पासवर्ड हो गए,
क्रेडिट कार्ड डिटेल्स हो गई। ये सब चीजें
क्लिकिंग मलेशियस लिंक ऐसी लिंक्स जो
मलेशियस हो
जिसमें कोई हिडन चीज हो जो
सामने वाले
यूजर के
लैपटॉप पे कंप्यूटर पे जैसे ही वो क्लिक
करे कोई मशियस वर्क कर परफॉर्म करने लगे
एग्जीक्यूट करने लगे डाउनलोडिंग मालवेयर
मैलवेयरस
या वायरसेस ट्रोजंस इन सबको डाउनलोड कर
दें। मैर्स के अंदर ही वायरसेस, ट्रोजंस
यह सब आते हैं। वर्म्स आते हैं। तो कुछ भी
डाउनलोड हो सकता है। मनी ट्रांसफरिंग
बैंकिंग वेबसाइट्स वगैरह इन सब पे बहुत
सारी फिशिंग्स अटैक्स होते हैं। जहां पे
यूजर को लगता है कि वो एक जेन्युइन बैंक
अकाउंट बैंक के पेज पे लॉगिन कर रहा है।
बट ऐसा होता नहीं है। एंड इंस्टॉलिंग
रिमोट एक्सेस टूल्स मतलब रिमोटली कंट्रोल
करने वाले टूल्स को एक्सेस करना। यानी कि
रैट्स, रिमोट एक्सेस ट्रोजंस इन सबको भी
इंस्टॉल करने के
मोटिव से फिशिंग जो है
वह यूजर्स को ट्रिक करते हैं इन फिशिंग के
अंदर में। सिंपल सा फंडा है। अब यहां पे
है इट अटैक ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी नॉट जस्ट
सिस्टम्स। ये ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी को अटैक
करते हैं।
ठीक है? ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी को अटैक करते
हैं। प्लीज आप लोग जो जितने भी लोग हैं
लाइक कर दीजिएगा एंड सब्सक्राइब मार ही
दीजिएगा। लाइक तो जरूर कर दीजिएगा। ये
ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी को अटैक करते हैं। नॉट
जस्ट सिस्टम्स सिस्टम्स को अटैक नहीं
करते।
मैं आपको बताऊं यहां पे तो एक वेबसाइट है
एंटीf
यहां पे एक वेबसाइट है अ
लेट मी सी
धन्यवाद धन्यवाद
थैंक यू गाइस थैंक यू।
यहां पे एक वेबसाइट है इज इटf.org
ठीक है? मान लो आपके कोई भी यूआरएल है या
कोई ब्रांड नेम है कोई सबनेट है। आप यहां
पे उसको डाल सकते हैं एंड चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं कि ये फिशिंग के लिए टेस्ट आप चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? फिशिंग के लिए। तो फिशिंग के लिए
चेक आउट करेंगे। आपको बता देगा यह कि
एग्जैक्टली जो है
जैसे मैं मान लो यहां पर Amazon सर्च करता
हूं और मैं यहां पे एंटर करता हूं। लेट्स
सी सर्चिंग Amazon एंड एंट्री।
अब मैं यहां पे जब सर्च कर रहा हूं तो आप
देखेंगे यहां पे कि Amazon से रिलेटेड
जितने भी फिशिंग के वेबसाइट्स हैं या
यूआरएल से हैं वो आपको मिल जाएंगे। जैसे
यहां पे एंड इनकी कब यह डिटेक्ट हुई थी यह
भी आपको पता चल जाएगा।
यह देखो आप यहां पे यह कोई लिंक है जो कि
Amazon की फिशिंग पेज को होस्ट कर रही थी
या फिशिंग पेज को बेसिकली चला रही थी एंड
यह डिटेक्शन में आ गई है। तो इस तरीके से
आपको
इस वेबसाइट का यूज़ करके आप ऐसी वेबसाइट्स
को यूज़ करके एंड फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स जो है
जो एक पर्टिकुलर ब्रांड से रिलेटेड हो या
वेबसाइट से रिलेटेड हो आप निकाल सकते हैं।
एक तो ये हो गया। अब यहां पे एक और
वेबसाइट है फिश टैंक।
फिश टैंक फिश टैंक को ओपन करेंगे। यह एक
ऐसा डेटाबेस है जहां पे आप किसी भी यूआरएल
को डालेंगे तो यह बताएगा कि इट्स अ
एक्चुअली फिशिंग वेबसाइट और इट्स अ
जेन्युइन वेबसाइट।
यह आपको बताएगा फिश टैंक.com
तो यहां पर लिस्ट भी आपको मिलेंग जो अभी
रिसेंटली फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स डिटेक्ट हुई
हैं एंड फिशिंग पेज को होस्ट करती है।
जैसे ये लिंक है
लेट्स सी।
आई डोंट थिंक आई कैन एक्सेस इट। बट लेट्स
सी। नहीं ओपन हो रही है।
यहां पे एक लिंक है। इसको ओपन करके देखते
हैं।
हां। अब ये लिंक है। अब दिस इज़ अ फिशिंग
वेबसाइट। अब आपको समझ में आएगा नहीं कि
एग्जैक्टली ये फिशिंग क्या है? कैसे है?
यू विल नॉट अंडरस्टैंड। बट एग्जैक्टली दिस
इज़ अ फिशिंग वेबसाइट। ये एक फिशिंग
वेबसाइट ही है जो आपको यहां पे दिख रहा
है। सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो यहां पे आप
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड डालेंगे। एंड दैट्स इट।
डन। किस्सा खत्म। तो यहां पर जो लिस्टेड
वेबसाइट्स हैं जिनमें फिशिंग डिटेक्ट हुई
है वो यहां पे आपको लिस्ट मिल जाएगी। आप
खुद भी अकाउंट बना के यहां पे वेबसाइट्स
को लिस्ट कर पाएंगे। फिशिंग वाली जो भी
वेबसाइट्स हैं उसको लिस्ट कर पाएंगे। ठीक
है? या करेक्ट। अब्सोलुटली करेक्ट।
सर आई हैव बिल्ट अ फिशिंग सेमुलेशन।
टूल सिमिलर टू गो फिश इज दैट इनफ फॉर अ
प्रोजेक्ट या इट्स मोर दैन इनफ अगर गो फिफ
फिश की तरह आपने बना लिया है इट्स मोर दैन
इनफ जेट फिशर इज़ अ पावरफुल टूल फॉर फिशिंग
यस जेट फिशर इज़ अ गुड टूल फॉर फिशिंग इट्स
अब्सोलुटली इट्स एक्चुअली गुड टूल फॉर
फिशिंग आई एक्चुअली वाउच फॉर दैट आई एम
वाउचिंग फॉर दैट सो जेट फिशर भी एक अच्छा
टूल है बिल्कुल सही बोला आपने ठीक है तो
ये आपको समझ में आ गई होगी यहां पे आके आप
फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स को सबमिट भी कर सकते हो
और फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स के लिस्ट भी चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं जो हमेशा रेगुलरली फिशिंग जो
है वो एसेट्स को यहां पे सबमिट किया जाता
है डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट यूज़र्स की तरफ से एंड
ताकि एक सिक्योर एंड स्पैम फ्री
एनवायरमेंट बना रहे। दैट्स इट।
हां, आज की क्लास थोड़ी पहले से स्टार्ट
हुई है गाइस। अगर जो लोग बाद में आ रहे
हैं उनको पहले ही बता दे रहा हूं। तो ये
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा फिशिंग क्या होती
है। मैंने पहले ही इन्फॉर्म करा था। देखो
अगर जिसको नहीं पता कि आज की क्लास पहले
से स्टार्ट हो रही है। मैं आपको पहले ही
इसलिए बोलता हूं कि WhatsApp चैनल एंड
WhatsApp ग्रुप दोनों ज्वाइन कर लो। मैंने
पहले ही आप लोगों को इनफॉर्म करवा दिया था
कि आज की सेशन जो है वो थोड़ी पहले
स्टार्ट होगी 6:30 से। राइट?
चलिए
अब आते हैं फिशिंग के टाइप्स में। फिशिंग
के डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स होते हैं।
जिसमें कि एक ईमेल फिशिंग आता है, स्पेयर
फिशिंग आता है, वेलिंग आता है, स्मिसिंग
एंड वेशिंग आता है, फार्मिंग आता है। यह
सारी चीजें जो है फिशिंग के अ टाइप्स हैं।
इविल ट्विन अटैक आता है। देन आपकी ये सारी
टाइप्स हैं। अब हम फिशिंग के टाइप्स में
सबसे पहला टाइप देखेंगे। वो है हमारा ईमेल
फिशिंग।
अब ईमेल फिशिंग में क्या होता है? मैं
आपको पहले बता देता हूं। विक्टिम रिसीव्स
फेक ईमेल। यह एक कॉमन सी चीज है। बहुत
सारे लोग फेक ईमेल को रिसीव करते हैं। फेक
ईमेल्स उनको आते रहते हैं। मुझे तो रेगुलर
बेसिस पे आता है। लिटरली मैं आपको अभी
रीसेंट का भी अगर कोई फिशिंग ईमेल दिखाना
चाहूं तो लेट मी सी इफ आई कैन शो यू
समथिंग।
लेट मी सी।
ओ
हम
चलिए मैं आपको
मैं आपको
फिशिंग का एक लाइव एग्जांपल भी दिखा देता
हूं मैं जो मुझे ही आती है। जनरली आती ही
रहती है। जनरली अलग-अलग तरह की
फिशिंग की अटेम्प्ट्स होते हैं। फिशिंग के
तरीके होते हैं।
मैं आपको अभी लाइव एक फिशिंग का एग्जांपल
दिखा देता हूं। सो आई एम ओपनिंग माय Gmail
अकाउंट। मैं अपना Gmail अकाउंट ओपन कर रहा
हूं।
लेट्स सी। एंड यहां पे एक मेल है जो मुझे
आया हुआ है।
दिस मेल हैड अराइव्ड ऑन 11th ऑफ़ फरवरी।
आज 19 है। 8 दिन पहले की बात है।
पेड यूजीसी अपॉर्चुनिटी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
या वीपीए मेल आया है विज़न प्रो प्रोमो
एजेंसी@gmail.com
से इनसे मेल आया हुआ है। क्या लिखा है
इन्होंने? हाय टेक्निकल नेविगेटर टीम। आई
केम अक्रॉस अक्रॉस योर कंटेंट एंड रियली
लाइक्ड हाउ यू ब्रेक डाउन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ऑन ऑनलाइन प्राइवेसी
टॉपिक्स इन अ क्लियर प्रैक्टिकल वे। आई एम
माइकल एंड आई हेल्प साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड
वीpए ब्रांड्स रन पेड यूजी यूजीसी कैंपेन
एंड क्रिएटर्स विद क्रिएटर्स। आई करेंटली
वर्किंग विथ अ वीपीएन साइबर सिक्योरिटी
ब्रांड दैट लुकिंग फॉर क्रिएटर टू
प्रोड्यूस शॉर्ट टर्म यूजीसी कंटेंट पेड
फोकस्ड ऑन प्राइवेसी सिक्योरिटी एंड
सेफ्टी सेफ इंटरनेट यूसेस। नो पोस्टिंग इज़
रिक्वायर्ड ऑन योर पर्सनल पेज। देखा वुड
यू बीन वुड यू बी ओपन टू मी शेयरिंग द
ब्रांड डिटेल्स डिलीवरेबल्स एंड रेट्स विद
यू माइकल विज़री विज़न प्रमोटिंग एजेंसी ये
जो भी है उसका इन्होंने एक फॉलो अप भी
डाला है। अब देखो अब ये मेल बहुत जेन्युइन
हो सकता है। आपको जेन्युइन लग भी सकता है
एंड इट माइट बी जेन्युइन मेल हो सकता है।
पॉसिबल है। बट इस मेल का मोटिव क्या है?
व्हाट इज द मोटिव ऑफ दिस काइंड ऑफ़ मेल?
यहां पे सबसे पहली चीज आपको नोट करनी होती
है कि यहां पे जो मेल आया है मुझे अगर यह
एक्चुअली स्पॉन्सर मेल होता तो एक डोमेन
ये डोमेन Gmail पहली बात तो Gmail डोमेन
से होती ही नहीं। मोस्ट प्रोबेबबली मोस्ट
चांसेस आर देयर कि Gmail इज़ नॉट बीइंग
यूज़्ड एंड देयर ओन डोमेन इज़ बीइंग यूज़्ड
फॉर द ईमेल आईडीज़। दूसरी चीज यह अपने किसी
ना किसी वेबसाइट, किसी ना किसी ऐप या किसी
ना किसी तरह के किसी भी तरह की कोई लिंक
हमें जरूर प्रोवाइड करते इसी के साथ जहां
पे हम उनके डिटेल्स देख पाते हैं। मुझे
पता ही नहीं है यार कि ये कौन सी कंपनी
है? यूजीसी कैंपेन विद क्रिएटर। आई केम
अक्रॉस योर भाई खुद का तो बताओ। विज़न
प्रमोशन एजेंसी। अब ये विज़न प्रमोशन
एजेंसी अगर मैं यहां पे
सर्च मारू तो यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं आएगा।
यहां पे एक ऐसी फर्जी वेबसाइट्स कुछ आएंगी
यहां पे जैसे एक प्रोमो विज़न इसकी वेबसाइट
का लिंक कुछ और है। डोमेन कुछ और है या
मुझे कुछ और तरीके से मेल आ रहा है। तो ये
क्लियरली फर्जी दिख रही है। क्लियर फर्जी
दिख रहा है। अब ऐसे मेल्स जब आते हैं ये
फिशिंग अटेम्प्ट होती हैं। एंड ऐसे मेल्स
के चक्कर में बहुत सारे बड़े-बड़े
क्रिएटर्स पहले पड़ चुके हैं। जिनकी
YouTube की अकाउंट हैक और कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो
चुकी है। आपको तो पता ही है कि कैसे-कैसे
दिग्गज लोगों की YouTube कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुए
है। राइट? बड़े-बड़े मिलियंस
सब्सक्राइबर्स वाले यूटबर जिनको आप भी
देखते होंगे उनके भी YouTube कंप्रोमाइज
हुए लालच के चक्कर में। अब यह इतना टिंग
आपको लालच देंगे कि आओ एक छोटी सी वीडियो
करनी है और उसके उस छोटी सी वीडियो के लिए
आपको $5,000 मिलेंगे। अब बताओ
अब जो बड़े क्रिएटर्स हैं उनको तो
जेन्युइन लगेगा। लगेगा कि चलो ₹5,000 दे
रहे हैं। हमारी ब्रांड है, हमारी अपनी
पहचान है। तो छोटी सी वीडियो के ₹5,000 दे
सकते हैं। बट अगर यही सेम मेल अगर किसी
छोटे क्रिएटर को भेज दिया जाए तो वो तो
पागल हो जाएगा। वो सोचेगा इतनी छोटी इतना
मैं छोटा क्रिएटर हूं $5000 देंगे एक छोटी
सी चीज़ के लिए तो उसको डाउट होना शुरू हो
जाता है। बट बड़े क्रिएटर्स को डाउट जल्दी
नहीं होता है क्योंकि उनको लगता है कि
मेरी फेस वैल्यू इतनी है। मैं इतना वर्थ
हूं कि मुझे 5000 तो उनको लगता है ये
जेन्युइन है। तो उस चक्कर में वो फंस जाते
हैं। किसी छोटे क्रिएटर को देखा है कभी
जल्दी फंसते हुए क्योंकि उसको बिलीव ही
नहीं होगा। बड़े क्रिएटर को तुरंत बिलीव
होगा। दैट्स व्हाई दीज़ काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स आर
वै सक्सेसफुल।
करेक्ट। तो दीज़ काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स आर वै
सक्सेसफुल ओनली बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ दीज़ काइंड ऑफ़
रीज़ंस। सिंपल सा फंडा है। अब
विक्टिम को एक फेक मेल रिसीव होता है।
ईमेल्स जो होती है वो बहुत लेजिटमेट दिखता
है। बैंक के तरफ से हो सकता है। किसी बड़े
कंपनी के तरफ से हो सकता है। किसी आपके
रीसेंट कूरियर कंपनी या रीसेंट कोई अगर
आपने चीजें ऑर्डर की है उससे रिलेटेड हो
सकता है।
अब इन ईमेल्स में क्या होते हैं? मलेशियस
लिंक्स होते हैं। फेक लॉग इन पेजेस के
लिंक्स होते हैं। इनफेक्टेड अटैचमेंट्स
होते हैं। अटैचमेंट्स पीडीएफ या किसी भी
तरह की कोई और फाइल हो सकती है जिसमें कि
अटैचमेंट्स जो है मलशियस तरीके से इनबिल्ट
डाला जा सके। मलसियस तरीके से उसको कंबाइन
किया जा सके। तो ये सारी चीजें आपकी ईमेल
फिशिंग में होती है। ईमेल फिशिंग। तो उसके
बाद यूजर उससे इंटरेक्ट करता है एंड
क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुरा लिए जाते हैं
इंटरेक्शन के बाद या मेलवेस को उस सिस्टम
पे इंस्टॉल कर दिया जाता है। अब इन ईमेल
फिशिंग्स के लिए कॉमन टैक्टिक्स क्या-क्या
है? तो कॉमन टैक्टिक्स में क्या-क्या
चीजें आपको सामने से देखने को सुनने को
मिल सकती है? योर अकाउंट विल बी सस्पेंडेड
इनवॉइस अटैच्ड क्लिक टू रिसीट पासवर्ड
सैलरी इंक्रीमेंट डिटेल्स कूरियर डिलीवरी
फेल्ड। अब अभी रिसेंट में मैंने एक
Twitter पे पोस्ट देखा। वहां पे किसी ने
भी लिखा था कि
उसको टेस्ट करना था अपने एंप्लाइजज़ को। अ
जितने भी एंप्लाइजज़ थे अलग-अलग
डिपार्टमेंट के उसने क्या किया? एक पीडीएफ
फाइल
एक पीडीएफ फाइल जनरेट करी विथ ऑल द
डिटेल्स एंड एक एक प्रॉपर मतलब एक जेरिक
साइज में जैसे पीडीएफ फाइल 202 MB की हुई।
ठीक है? जेन्युइन साइज है और उस पीडीएफ
में एक ट्रोजन को बाइंड कर दिया। एक
ट्रोजन मतलब एक रिमोट एक्सेस ट्रोजन आर
एटी रैट को बाइंड कर दिया। ठीक है? अब
उसने क्या किया? उस पर्टिकुलर ट्रोजन वाली
फाइल पीडीएफ को क्या नाम दिया पता है?
2026 सैलरी इंक्रीमेंट लिस्ट यह नाम दे
दिया डॉट pdf.exc
बस सैलरी इंक्रीमेंट पीडीएफ सैलरी
इंक्रीमेंट pdf
excpdf
या pdf exc ऐसे करके एक्सटेंशन का गेम हो
गया। अब ये जो सैलरी वाली पीडीएफ ये लोगों
को जब लोगों ने देखा उस कंपनी के उनको लगा
अरे यार हमारी 2026 में सैलरी बढ़ने वाली
है। चलो देखो देखो यार किसका नाम है किसका
कितना इनक्रीस हो रहा है। इवन इंसिडेंट
रिस्पांस टीम फेल्ड फॉर दैट। इस इंसिडेंट
रिस्पांस टीम के भी बंदों ने उसको ओपन कर
लिया। उन्होंने ईएक्स और उन्होंने बाकी
चीजों पर ध्यान ही नहीं दिया। तो यह होता
है ह्यूमन के माइंड के साथ खेलना। ह्यूमन
के माइंड को मैनपुलेट कर देना। ह्यूमन के
माइंड को अपने अकॉर्डिंग परफॉर्म करवाना।
और आप जैसा चाहते हो वैसा सामने वाला करे।
उस तरीके से अटैक करना सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
के थ्रू। दिस इज़ द पावर ऑफ़ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। दिस इज़ द ब्यूटी ऑफ़ सोशल
इंजीनियर। एंड दैट्स व्हाई आई लव सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग। मुझे सोशल इंजीनियरिंग से
ज्यादा बड़ा खतरनाक अटैक। और कोई अटैक लगता
ही नहीं है। अभी तक के जितने भी अटैक्स
हैं लिटरली हो गया फिर अटैक।
क्या कर लिया?
व्हाट यू डीड एक्चुअली कुछ नहीं। टाइम पे
तो कुछ नहीं कर पाए।
तो इस तरीके से
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के अटैक्स होते हैं।
हम
समझ में आया अभी तक आपको इतना
अ प्लीज एवरीबडी लेट मी नो।
डड यू डू डड यू अंडरस्टैंड दिस ईमेल
फिशिंग
ईमेल के थ्रू जो फिशिंग अटैक्स हो रहे हैं
वो ईमेल फिशिंग कहलाते हैं। एंड ईमेल्स
फिशिंग जो होती हैं उसमें एसओसी के
डिटेक्शन इंडिकेटर्स में किस तरह की चीजें
आती हैं? ईमेल फ्रॉम स्पूफ डोमेन यह पहला
मतलब एक ऐसी डोमेन जो स्पूफ डोमेन है वहां
से ईमेल आना डोमेनस लुक्स सिमिलर
microsoft को microsoft.com
ऐसे लिख देना सस्िशियस अटैचमेंट्स ऐसे
अटैचमेंट्स जो एक अह जो एक तरह के
अह जैसे इज़प
एग्जीक्यूटेबल टाइप अटैचमेंट्स जो होते
हैं जिसको ओपन करने पे अंदर से कुछ चीजें
ऐसी एग्जीक्यूट हो सकती हैं ऑटोमेटिक ऑटो
कि आपके सिस्टम पे वो रन कर जाएंगी जैसे
ही आप उसको
अटैचमेंट को
सिंपल
एक्सट्रैक्ट करोगे।
देन यूआरएल रीडायरेक्ट चेस जहां पे एक
यूआरएल से दूसरे यूआरएल पे रीडायरेक्ट
किया जाता है। एक कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड सर्वर से
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट
किया जाए। कुछ इस तरीके की चीजें एनएसपीएफ
डीके आई एम डीएम एआरसी फेलियर जहां पे
आपको मेल सर्वर आपका जो है वो ऑथेंटिकेट
करने में फेल कर जा रहा है आपकी ईमेल आईडी
को आपकी जो भी मेल आईडी है या जो भी आपका
मेल सर्विस यूज़ कर रहे हैं उसको।
तो इस केस में ये ईमेल फिशिंग के कुछ
डिटेक्शन इंडिकेटर्स थे। अब यहां पर ईमेल
फिशिंग में आप देखेंगे कि इस तरीके की
चीजें जैसे कोई मेल आ रही है तो आपके पास
मल्टीपल चांसेस हैं। मल्टीपल चीजें हैं
जहां पे आप
पहचान सकते हैं कि यह एग्जैक्टली ईमेल
फिशिंग है या नहीं। कुछ लोग पूछ रहे हैं
सर डीकेआईएम ये सब क्या होता है? एसपीएफ
डीकेआईएम डीएमएआरसी सेंडर्स पॉलिसी
फ्रेमवर्क सूट मैं आपको वैसे तो मैं आपको
अह इसकी फुल फॉर्म बताने के लिए नहीं हूं।
बट स्टिल दीज़ आर द दीज़ आर द डीएनएस
टीएक्सटी रिकॉर्ड एंट्री फॉर एनी काइंड ऑफ़
डोमेन व्हिच मेक्स इंश्योर दैट यू आर
रिसीविंग एंड सेंडिंग द ईमेल्स फ्रॉम योर
ओन डोमेन ईमेल आईडीज़ जैसे अगर आपके पास एक
डोमेन है dfonic.com
तो आपका अगर ईमेल आईडी है nitesh.fronic
nitish@ dfonic.com तो आप उस ईमेल आईडी से
किसी और को मेल भेज पाएं किसी भी
पर्टिकुलर किसी भी दूसरे मेल आई चाहे
Gmail हो, Hotmail हो, Yahoo हो और आपके
पास उन लोगों के मेल आ जाए। इसको मेक
श्योर करने के लिए यह एंट्रीज टीxटी
रिकॉर्ड डीएनएस की एक टीx रिकॉर्ड है।
उसमें ये चीज जानी होती है। अदरवाइज ईमेल
डिलीवरी का रेट कम हो सकता है। हो सकता है
आपके मैक्सिमम मेल्स जो है वो स्पैम में
चली जाएं। तो ये जरूरी है। तो यही ये लिखा
हुआ है कि एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन में इस तरह के
फेलियर भी आ सकते हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
कुछ इस तरीके से राइट में इमेज है आपकी।
यहां पे आप दिख आपको दिख रहा होगा हाय
वेबसाइट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर। बोल्डिंग इट डज़
नॉट मेक इट माय नेम। अब यार एडम वेबसाइट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर कौन है भाई? नाम तो बताओ।
ऐसे ही कुछ भी लिख दे रहे हो। मैं क्यों
अटेंड करूंगा? सिंपल सा फंडा है। आजकल
बहुत सारे केसेस हैं। इंक्रीस द
प्रॉफिटेबिलिटी थ्रू क्लिक थ्रू रेट्स
फ्रॉम पीसी कैंपेन।
अब ये क्या बोल रहा है? कुछ समझ में नहीं
आ रहा है।
प्रॉफिटेबिलिटी को इंक्रीस कर दीजिए।
थ्रू पीपीसी कैंपेन ये क्या है? व्हाट इज़
दिस? सो कुछ भी लिख देना। यहां पे देखोगे
लिंक बिल्डिंग कॉपीराइटिंग। अब ये
कॉपीराइटिंग का स्पेलिंग देखो भाई। सी
यहां पे क्या होता है? सी ओ पी वाई
डब्ल्यू आर आई टी आई यू एन जी यह तो होता
है यह कॉपी राइटिंग एकदम दिल पे ले लिखा
है इसने भैया ने दिल पर लिख के ले दिल पे
लिख के कर दिया ये ईमेल फिशिंग ये ईमेल
फिशिंग के पार्ट्स है दीज़ आर ऑल कॉल्ड
ईमेल फिशिंग अब आते हैं स्पीयर फिशिंग
स्पीयर फिशिंग में क्या होता है अब देखो
ईमेल फिशिंग में मैंने आपको कुछ टर्म्स
बताए एसपीएफ डीके आई एम डीएम एआरसी अब इन
टर्म्स को आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि आपको
एक्सप्लोर करना है आपको अपने से भी इन
टर्म्स के बारे में पढ़ना है। यही तो आपके
टास्क होते हैं। हर सेशन के अंदर ऐसे
टास्क आपको मिलेंगे। ऑलमोस्ट मिलेंगे।
कुछ-कुछ सेशंस में ना हो माइंड मत करना
जिसमें जिसमें मिलेंगे। तो आपको इन टास्क
को कंप्लीट करना है। अब इन टास्क में सबसे
पहला है एसपीएफ, डीके, आईएम, डीएम, आरसी
के बारे में थोड़ा पढ़ना। थोड़ी बहुत
जानकारी लेना एंड देन आके मुझे बताना।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। आप कैसे बता सकते हैं
मुझे? ग्रुप में बता सकते हैं, मेल करके
बता सकते हैं या Lindin पे आप सबसे अच्छा
है कि Lindin पे आप हमें टैग कर दीजिए एंड
इसकी डिटेल्स पॉइंट वाइज़ नोट करके हमें
टैग कर दीजिए। हमें पता चल जाएगा। दैट्स
इट सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो ये होती है हमारी
ईमेल फिशिंग। अब ईमेल फिशिंग में जो मेल
आपके पास आ रहे हैं। तो अब यहां पे
@gmail.com यूज़ हुआ है। तो भैया यहां पे
आपका खुद का डोमेन नहीं है क्या? झूठ-मोट
का आपने वेबसाइट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर लिख के
इसको बोल्ड कर दिया है। भैया नाम तो यहां
पे लिखो। कुछ भी तो ऐसा लिखो। ऑथेंटिसिटी
आए सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो जहां पर
ऑथेंटिसिटी को हाइड करने की कोशिश की जाए
जिस ईमेल के थ्रू वह ईमेल फिशिंग के
कैटेगरी में जनरली आ जाती है।
अब आती है स्पेयर फिशिंग। स्पेयर फिशिंग
का मतलब है टारगेटेड फिशिंग अगेंस्ट अ
स्पेसिफिक पर्सन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। अगर किसी
एक स्पेसिफिक पर्सन के अगेंस्ट कोई फिशिंग
अटैक ल्च किया जा रहा हो या स्पेसिफिक
किसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अटै के अगेंस्ट
तो अगर स्पेसिफिक किसी पर्सन या
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अगेंस्ट अगर अटैक किया जा
रहा है तो उसको हम बोलते हैं
स्पेयर फिशिंग अटैक। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
जैसे कि कोई कंपनी बड़ी कंपनी है Lindin,
किसी कंपनी की वेबसाइट हो, किसी कंपनी का
सोशल हैंडल हो या किसी कंपनी के एम्प्लाइज
बड़े-बड़े कंपनी Lindin, Microsoft,
Google,
X ऐसी कंपनीज़ के एम्प्लाइजज़ के अगेंस्ट
टारगेट किया जा रहा हो, कंपनी की वेबसाइट
के अगेंस्ट टारगेट किया जा रहा हो, Lindin
को टारगेट किया, Lindin जैसी कंपनीज़ को
टारगेट किया जा रहा हो। उस केस में इनको
हम बोलते हैं स्पेयर फिशिंग। एग्जांपल
अटैकर्स
अटैकर ईमेल एचआर एचआर को ईमेल करता है कि
अटैकर क्या हाय
दिस इज द चीफ फाइनेंसियल ऑफिसर
प्लीज ट्रांसफर 5 लै अर्जेंटली इसने अटैकर
ने एचआर को ये चीज मेल करी है या भेजा है।
दिस इज़ आल्सो कॉल्ड बिज़नेस ईमेल
कॉम्प्रोमाइज बीईसी।
अब इसका मतलब क्या हुआ
कि एक अटैकर ने बिजनेस ईमेल का यूज करके
जो कि बिजनेस ईमेल कॉम्प्रोमाइज के अंदर
में आता है। एक नॉर्मल से एचआर को एक एचआर
को जो कि बहुत बड़ा रोल नहीं होता है।
कंपनी के हायरार्की में नॉर्मल सा रोल
छोटा सा रोल होता है। मेल किया कि दिस इज़
अ सीएफओ चीफ फाइनेंसियल ऑफिसर प्लीज सेंड
5 लै अर्जेंटली। अब एचआर सोचने में पड़
जाएंगे भाई कि भाई सीएफओ का मेल सीएफओ का
मैसेज आया है ऐसे कैसे इग्नोर कर दे पूछे
कैसे कि सर आपने सो देयर इज़ फियर
फियर है डर्ट है जिसके कारण ये चीजें
सक्सेसफुल हो जाती है ऐसी अटैक्स
व्हाई इट इज़ डेंजरस लुक्स एक्सट्रीमली
लेजिटमेट ऑफन बाईपास स्पैम फिल्टर्स हाई
फाइनेंसियल डैमेज ऐसी चीजें हमेशा
लेजिटमेट लगती है अरे भैया हां सीएफओ साहब
ने किया है ऐसी जो चीजें हैं वो वो
फिल्टर्स को बाईपास कर देती हैं क्योंकि
भैया यहां पे तो ह्यूमन टू ह्यूमन एंड
पर्सन टू पर्सन बातें हो रही हैं। तो क्या
ही फिल्टर क्या है स्पैन एंड यहां पे
फाइनेंसियल डैमेज जो होता है वो
अनइमेजिनेबल
एंड बहुत ही बड़े लेवल पे ये डैमेज होता
है। नेक्स्ट लेवल पे ये डैमेज होता है जो
यहां पे ये डैमेज होता है। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड
अ
दिस इज़ कॉल्ड स्पेयर फिशिंग।
ठीक है? अब आते हैं वेलिंग। अब वेलिंग पे
आते हैं। वेलिंग क्या होती है? देखो
फिशिंग के डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स हैं। अब
अलग-अलग टाइप्स जो होते हैं ना अलग-अलग
तरीके की नेचर को शो करते हैं। अब इसी में
एक वेलिंग आता है। ये एक ऐसा फिशिंग
अटेमप्ट है, फिशिंग अटैक है जो हाई लेवल
एग्जीक्यूटिव्स को टारगेट करता है। जैसे
सीईओ, सीएफओ, सीईओ, डायरेक्टर्स ऐसी
एग्जीक्यूटिव्स को टारगेट करता है। तो
यहां पे
इंपैक्ट भी हाई होगा, रिवॉर्ड भी हाई
होगा, रिस्क भी हाई होगा। तो अभी जैसे आप
देखो यहां पर राइट साइड में एक इमेज है।
यहां पर फ्रॉम फ्रैंक राइट इन्होंने एक
मेल करा है। किसको? क्रिस स्मूथ को। क्या
सब्जेक्ट डाला है? कॉन्फिडेंशियल एंड
अर्जेंट। कैट हाय क्रिस आई नीड योर हेल्प
विद समथिंग दैट्स बोथ कॉन्फिडेंशियल एंड
एक्सट्रीमली अर्जेंट। प्लीज रिसोंड बाय
ईमेल एएसएपी एज़ सून एज़ पॉसिबल। आई कैन नॉट
टेक कॉल्स रिगार्ड्स फ्रैंक सीईओ
example.com अब यह सीईओ है। इन्होंने
अर्जेंट में किसको मैसेज किया है? ने मेल
किया हुआ है भैया सिंपल सा क्रिश को सिंपल
क्रिश को यहां पे इन्होंने मेल कर दिया अब
इन्होंने जब मेल किया इन्होंने क्या बोला
कि भैया कुछ कॉन्फिडेंशियल एंड कुछ
एक्सट्रीमली अर्जेंट है जल्दी से जल्दी
रिप्लाई करो कॉल मैं नहीं ले पाऊंगा ये
चीजें जो है आपको समझनी पड़ेगी कि कैसे
इनको टैकल करना है। ऐसी चीजों को सिचुएशन
को कैसे समझे कि ये जेन्युइन सिचुएशन है।
ये एक्चुअली एक फिशिंग सिचुएशन है। जहां
पे सामने वाला हमें बेवकूफ बना रहा है।
मुझे बेवकूफ बना रहा है। मेरे मैनेजर को,
मेरे सीनियर को बेवकूफ बना रहा है।
राइट?
अ हां बिल्कुल सही। अ
बिल्कुल। दिस इज़ अ लैक ऑफ स्लिप। हां,
थोड़ा लैक ऑफ स्लिप है।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल है बिल्कुल आपने
सही बोला
तभी तो मैंने बोला कि मैं अगर इतनी चीज
ऐसी चीजों के बाद भी आपकी सेशन ले रहा हूं
तो भी आप अगर नहीं आ रहे हो तो फिर व्हाट
आई कैन व्हाट कैन आई से
व्हाट कैन आई से
ओके
थैंक्स नेक्स्ट निंजा थैंक्स
बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल एमो नाम इन बिल्कुल शोरली
नहीं आज का सेशन तो जरूरी था आपके लिए
क्योंकि काफी टाइम हो गया था काफी टाइम हो
गया था दैट्स व्हाई टुडे सेशन वाज़ वेरी
वेरीेंट सो दैट्स व्हाई आई एम हियर टू टेक
द सेशन बट अगर आप
ओके थैंक यू नमन थैंक यू फॉर द सुपर चैट
बेइज्जती नहीं हुई है। वेरी वेरीरी थैंक
यू फॉर दैट
बिल्कुल दानिश बिल्कुल
अभी यार अभी यार अभी अभी टाइम है यार अभी
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
चलिए तो यहां पे हम आते हैं वेलिंग के ऊपर
में। वेलिंग का मतलब होता है फिशिंग
टारगेटिंग हाई लेवल एग्जीक्यूटिव सीएफओ
सीईओ इन सबको जब टारगेट किया जाता है तो
अब देख सकते हो अभी किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
बंदे ने एक सीईओ ने क्या मेल किया क्रिश
को कि भैया जल्दी-जल्दी चाहिए जल्दी मुझे
एक डिटेल्स चाहिए कुछ जल्दी रिप्लाई करो
अब वो बंदा डर जाएगा अरे सीईओ का मेल है
यार सीईओ ने मेल करा है तो कुछ तो बात
होगी तो दिस इज़ काइंड ऑफ़ क्रिएटिंग
अर्जेंसी एंड मैनपुलेटिंग बीइंग एन हाई
लेवल एग्जीक्यूटिव कि भैया आप तो ये
डिटेल्स हमें दे तो इसको हम वेलिंग बोलते
हैं। एंड देन हम आते हैं स्मिशिंग एंड
विशिंग पे। देखो
आज की अच्छा गाइज़ आप लोगों को मैं पहले
इनफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं। आज की सेशन अगर
थोड़ी छोटी हो शॉर्ट हो तो चलेगा। कोई
दिक्कत आप लोगों को तो नहीं होगी। मुझे
बता दीजिए एक बार।
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीबॉडी। आई वांट
रिस्पांस फ्रॉम एवरीबॉडी।
इज देयर एनी इशू? कोई इशू है आपको?
थोड़ी आज श हो तो?
थैंक यू। धन्यवाद। बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद।
चलिए थैंक यू वेरी मच।
ओके। थैंक यू।
चलिए अच्छी बात है। आप लोग समझ पा रहे
हैं। अच्छी बात है। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
आई हैव फिशिंग एंड लेंस कैंपेन इन माय
कंपनी। दैट्स ग्रेट। पीतांबर।
प्रैक्टिकल आने में अभी टाइम है यार।
थैंक यू सावन
थैंक यू लोकी
या थैंक यू थैंक यू
ओके थैंक्स ब्रदर
थैंक्स प्रवीण श्योर प्रवीण अ
थैंक यू फॉर अ गाइस थैंक यू फॉर द सपोर्ट
गाइस। रियली एप्रिशिएट योर सपोर्ट एवरीवन
सपोर्ट। एक्चुअली काफी अच्छा लगता है। देन
वी आर कमिंग टू द स्मेशिंग एंड विशिंग।
व्हाट इज द स्मेशिंग एंड विशिंग? देखो
स्मेशिंग का मतलब होता है ऐसा फिशिंग जो
एसएमएस के थ्रू हो। विशिंग का मतलब है ऐसा
फिशिंग जो फोन कॉल के थ्रू हो। सिंपल सा
फंडा है। आपको कांसेप्ट समझने हैं। आपको
एसओसी के लिए साइबर सिक्योरिटी मेंस्टरी
नहीं करनी है। यू डोंट हैव टू बिकम अ
मास्टर इन एव्री टॉपिक ऑफ़ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। यू हैव बट यू हैव टू बी
नॉलेजेबल। यू हैव टू टेक नॉलेज ऑफ़ द
टॉपिक्स दैट इज़ द पार्ट ऑफ़ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। तब आप एक अच्छे एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट बन सकते हैं। क्योंकि आपको
अटैक्स के बारे में पता होगा कि अटैक्स
किन-किन तरहों से कैसे-कैसे होती हैं। तो
आप उन तरीके से वैसे-वैसे आप उन अटैक्स से
सेव कट कर सकते हो अपने ऑपरेशंस को, अपनी
जो भी है कंपनीज़ को, नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
इसलिए हम ये चीजें पढ़ रहे हैं। यानी ये
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। इससे रिलेटेड
क्वेश्चंस भी आपसे
पूछ सकते हैं। पूछा जा सकता है। ठीक बात?
तो स्मिसिंग मतलब फिशिंग बाय एसएमएस।
फिशिंग मतलब फिशिंग बाय फोन कॉल। बस इतना
ही समझना है। जैसे कि योर बैंक अकाउंट इज़
ब्लॉक्ड। क्लिक हियर कोई लिंक एक दे देगा।
बस एसएमएस एसएमएस फिशिंग जिसको स्मिंग
बोलते हैं। अब विशिंग में आई एम फ्रॉम
ब्रांड फ्रॉड डिप आई एम फ्रॉम बैंक फ्रॉड
डिपार्टमेंट। टेल मी योर ओटीपी। अब भैया
मैं तो बैंक के फ्रॉड डिपार्टमेंट से हूं।
मुझे ओटीपी बताओ जल्दी। नहीं तो बैंड हो
जाएगा आपका। नहीं तो आपकी बैंक अकाउंट के
साथ दिक्कतें आ जाएंगी। तो वैसा हो तो समझ
लो कुछ तो झोल है कुछ तो तुरंत ओटीपी कोई
मांगे उसप अर्जेंसी दिखाएगा भैया ओटीपी दो
ना जल्दी ये हो जाएगा ओटीपी दो ना तो
सीधा-सीधा बोले भैया ओटीपी तुम रखो अपने
पास मैं अपने पास जो करना है कर लो आई विल
नॉट गिव द ओटीपी सिंपल सा फंडा है दैट्स
इट आप किसी भी बैंक से हो कोई ज्यादा बोले
बोले अच्छा कौन बैंक से बात कर रहे हो ये
बैंक से अच्छा ठीक है मैं आता हूं ना
मिलने आपसे आता हूं आपके ब्रांच में मिलने
मिलके बातें करेंगे यार जो ओडीपी वडीपी
चाहिए सामने ले लेना बस हो गया सिंपल सा
फंडा है
ठीक ठीक है? तो ये होती है स्मिंग एंड
विशिंग। अब इसी में एक आता है हमारा
फार्मिंग। दिस इज़ नॉट फार्मिंग। दिस इज़
फार्मिंग। फार्मिंग का मतलब होता है
फार्मिंग इज़ एन अटैक व्हेयर द विक्टिम इज़
रीडायरेक्टेड टू अ फेक वेबसाइट इवन इफ दे
टाइप द करेक्ट वेबसाइट एड्रेस।
अब वेबसाइट एड्रेस आपने करेक्ट डाला। मान
लो आपने वेबसाइट एड्रेस डाला Google.com।
ठीक है? अब आप एक रियल नहीं फेक
google.com पे रीडायरेक्ट हो जा रहे हो।
दिस इज़ अ बिग थिंग। दिस इज अ डेंजरस थिंग
और यह एक नेटवर्क के अंदर हो सकता है।
पॉसिबल है। अब एक ऐसे नेटवर्क से आप
कनेक्ट हो जाओ जहां पर पूरी डीएनएस की ऐसी
की तैसी हो रखी है। अब डीएनएस क्या कैसे
है वो मैं बताऊंगा आपको। वहां पे आप
Google टाइप करो और एक्चुअल में फेक
Google पे ट्रांसफर रीडायरेक्ट हो जाओ। तो
ये कितना डेंजरस है ना। आप अपने रियल
Google में लॉगिन करो। वहां रियल आपके
आईडी पासवर्ड्स सामने वाले के बंदे के पास
की लॉगिन की तरह पोइजनिंग इसका एग्जांपल
ही है। तो फार्मिंग में दो तरीके से
फार्मिंग होती है। एक डीएनएस पोइजनिंग के
थ्रू और एक होस्ट फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन के
थ्रू। जिसकी बात अभी कुछ टाइम पहले यहां
पे कोई एक बंदा कर रहा था डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
और और होस्ट फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन दोनों तरीके
से। अब डीएनएस पोइजनिंग का मतलब है अटैकर
कॉम्प्रोमाइज डीएनएस सर्वर और लोकल राउटर
व्हेन यूजर टाइप्स bank.com द डीएनs
रिटर्न्स अटैकर्स आईपी एड्रेस एंड यूज़र्स
लैंड्स ऑन फेक bank.com ऐसे होता है। अब
एक नेटवर्क है। एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में
डीएनएस सर्वर काम करता हो काम कर रहा होता
है। देखो होता क्या है? मान लो कि एक
नेटवर्क है। मान लो मेरे एक वाई-फाई
नेटवर्क से 10 कंप्यूटरटर्स, मोबाइल फोंस,
टैबलेट्स जुड़े पड़े हैं। अब अपने सभी 10
यूज़र्स जुड़े पड़े हैं। सभी लोग अपने-अपने
फोन में कोई Google खोल रहा है, कोई
Facebook खोल रहा है, कोई Instagram खोल
रहा है। ये सब कर रहे हैं। अब मैं अपने
नेटवर्क में एक डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
एनवायरमेंट सेटअप कर दूंगा। जहां पे मैं
क्या करूंगा कि मैं एक डीएनएस सर्वर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके मतलब मेरा ही मान लो है
मैं ही अटैकर हूं। कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके अपने
कंट्रोल में कर लूंगा। और मैं क्या करूंगा
कि एक पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल के लिए एक डिफरेंट
IPपी एड्रेस मैप कर दूंगा। डीएनएस कैश के
अंदर जब भी डीएनएस क्वेरीज होती है तो मान
लो कि कोई डीएनएस का काम होता है डोमेन
नेम को आईपीस के लिए कॉेस्पोंड करना। जो
भी डोमेन नेम आप टाइप करते हो ब्राउज़र में
जैसे Google.com तो ब्राउज़र को बेसिकली
डोमेन और अल्फाबेट से मतलब उसको IP चाहिए।
डीएनएस का काम होता है कि उस google.com
के लिए उसका IP लाकर लाकर देना कि भैया ये
जो डोमेन है इस IP पे मैप्ड है एंड आपको
इस आईपी से कनेक्ट करनी है। तो जो आईपी
होगी उसी पे कनेक्शन होगी। जब डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग होगी उस केस में अटैकर क्या
करेगा? आपके डीएनएस सर्वर के अंदर में
क्या करेगा कि एक पर्टिकुलर डोमेन के ऊपर
में एक फर्जी आईपी को ऐड कर देगा। वो आईपी
उस पर्टिकुलर अटैकर की आईपी होगी या अटैकर
की वेबसाइट की आईपी होगी। तो जैसे ही आप
एक रियल वेबसाइट खोलेंगे real.com आप
रीडायरेक्ट किस पे हो जाएंगे? fake.com पे
क्योंकि उसने डीएनएस पोइजनिंग करी है। अब
जब मैं टास्क की बात करता हूं तो एक टास्क
आपको मैं अभी भी यहीं पे दे देता हूं कि
गो एंड एक्सप्लोर डीएनएस पोइजनिंग कि
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग एक्सैक्टली क्या होता है।
दिस इज़ अ पार्ट ऑफ़ साइबर सिक्योरिटी
टॉपिक। एंड आई एज अ एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट आई
डोंट थिंक कि आपको बहुत डीप जाना है
इसमें। इतना डीप नहीं जाना है कि आपको
एक्सपर्ट बनना है। बट यू हैव टू गेट द
नॉलेज ऑफ़ डीएनएस पॉजिंग। यू शुड बी मोर
अवेयर अबाउट डीएस पोइजनिंग। कि इस तरीके
की चीजें भी होती है कि भैया आपके घर में
आके कोई आपके घर की दशा बदल दे। पता चले
कि ये दरवाजा खोलने पे पहले कुछ और देखने
को मिलता था। अब कुछ और देखने को मिल रहा
है। तो ये होती है डिसेंस पॉइंटिंग।
सिंपल। अब Google.com ओपन करने पे ब्राउज़र
में Google एक्चुअल Google का IP ओपन हो
तो चलेगा। Google.com ओपन होगा। बट
Google.com
ओपन करने पे कोई और IP एड्रेस पे वह
करेस्पोंड कर रहा है। कोई और IP एड्रेस
ओपन हो रही है। वह डेफ़ोनिक्स की IP एड्रेस
वहां पे ओपन हो रही है। इसका मतलब है
Google.com
डोमेन के लिए वहां पे डीएनएस पोइजनिंग हुई
है। एंड उस डोमेन को अब जबरदस्ती पॉइंट
कराया जा रहा है डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की वेबसाइट
पे। सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो, यह आपको अब
dfनिक्स की वेबसाइट पर अगर Google की फेक
वेबसाइट फेक पेज अगर होस्टेड होगी उस
वेबसाइट उस IPपी एड्रेस पे तो जैसे ही
Google.com कोई खोलेगा तो उसको एक फेक
Google.com का पेज मिलेगा और वहां पे अपनी
डिटेल्स ऐड करेगा और फिशिंग का शिकार हो
जाएगा। डीएनएस पोइजनिंग इसी को कहते हैं।
सिंपल।
तो डीएनएस पोइजनिंग समझ में आया?
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग आपको समझ में आया?
इतने से डीएनएस पोइजनिंग आप लोगों को समझ
में आया मुझे पहले बताइए। जस्ट लेट मी नो
इफ यू आर गेटिंग डीएनएस पोइजन
बताइए मुझे बताइए।
ओके
चलिए अच्छी बात है आर यू गेटिंग क्लियर
चलिए अच्छी बात है वेरी गुड बहुत बढ़िया इफ
यू आर गेटिंग
वेरी गुड
और क्या चाहिए भाई सब चीज आपको समझ में आ
रहा है और क्या चाहिए?
तो ये हमारी डीएनएस पोइजनिंग होती है। ठीक
है? ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग का।
अब
अब यहां पे आप देखेंगे डीएनएस पोइजनिंग
में एग्जैक्टली एग्जैक्टली डीएनएस
पोइजनिजिंग में क्या हो रहा है? यू वुड बी
सीइंग हियर।
यहां पे
डीएनएस सर्वर है आपका।
यह डीएनएस सर्वर है। अटैकर जो है डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग करता है। ठीक है? यूजर को ये
सर्व कर रहा होता है। डीएनएस सर्वर आपका।
अब जब यूजर कोई वेबसाइट ओपन करता है तो
डीएनएस सर्वर इसको सर्व करके उस वेबसाइट
के आईपी तक लेके जाता है। वेबसाइट तक
पहुंचाता है। जैसे ही अटैकर ने इस डीएनएस
सर्वर को पोइजन कर दिया।
तो उसके बाद अब यह डीएनएस सर्वर सेम डीएनए
सर्वर इस यूजर को एक रियल वेबसाइट की तरफ
ना ले जाके एक फर्जी वेबसाइट की तरफ लेके
चला जाएगा।
सिंपल क्योंकि डीएनएस सर्वर कंप्रोमाइज हो
चुका है। तो अब जिस आईपी पे रिॉल्व होना
चाहिए डोमेन को उस आईपी पे ना होके एक
अटैकर की आईपी पे रिॉल्व हो रहा है। जो
हैकर हमारे हैं ना उसके आईपी पे रिॉल्व हो
रहा है। तो google.com एक्चुअली Google के
सर्वर के आईपी पे रिज़ॉल्व नहीं हो रहा है।
कि IP पे नहीं जा रहा रीडायरेक्ट हो के।
वो एक फेक google.com के IP पे रिॉल्व हो
जा रहा है। क्योंकि अटैकर ने डीएनएस को ही
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया है। जो इस चीज़ के
लिए अ रिस्पांसिबल होता है डोमेन को IP
में कन्वर्ट करने या डोमेन को IP पे मैप
करने के लिए। सो ये डीएनएस पोइजनिंग है।
एज़ सिंपल एज़ दैट। सिंपल था। समझ में आना
चाहिए आपको।
ठीक है? दूसरा है होस्ट फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन।
ये आप सब में से कई लोग जानते होंगे कि
देखो Windows के अंदर में एक होस्ट फाइल
होता है जो कि Windows सिस्टम 32
ड्राइवर्स ईटीसी होस्ट इस लोकेशन पे होती
है। आप इस होस्ट फाइल को अगर जाके एडिट कर
देते हैं एंड वहां पे कुछ इस तरीके की
एंट्री करते हैं कि एक आईपी यहां डाल के
एंड यहां पे एक उसका अगेंस्ट एक डोमेन डाल
देते हैं तो अब यूजर जो है लोकली इस
पर्टिकुलर
IP पे रीडायरेक्ट हो जाएगा और उस bank.com
को ओपन करेगा तो वो उस IP को ओपन कर रहा
है। बेसिकली 19260.1
200 और वहां पे कोई मलेशियस वेबसाइट
होस्टेड है तो उस पे वह रीडायरेक्ट हो
जाएगा। इस तरीके से होस्ट फाइल के थ्रू
क्या होगा? फिशिंग अटैक हो सकती है लोकली।
अब फार्मिंग डेंजरस क्यों है? क्योंकि कोई
सस्िशियस ईमेल नहीं होती। इसमें ऑब्वियस
लिंक कोई नहीं होती। एक रियल डोमेन की तरह
उस वो दिखता है। एंड यूज़र्स के लिए बहुत
हार्ड हो जाता है डिटेक्शन में आना। तो यह
होती है फार्मिंग। फार्मिंग इसलिए काफी
ज्यादा डेंजरस एक अटैक कहा जाता है हमारे
फिशिंग के अंदर में। दैट्स दैट्स द थिंग।
सिंपल सा फंडा है।
ओके। ये आपको समझ में आई थिंक आ गया होगा।
काफी
होस्ट फाइल Windows के अंदर देखो मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं।
Windows के अंदर में जाओगे। सी के अंदर
में Windows के अंदर जाएंगे। यहां पे हमें
मिलेगा एक सिस्टम 32 फोल्डर। इसके अंदर
आपको मिलेगा ड्राइवर्स। इसके अंदर आपको
मिलेगा ईटीसी। इसके अंदर मिलेगा आपको
होस्ट्स। ये होस्ट फाइल होती है। अब इस
होस्ट फाइल को मैं अगर ओपन विद करता हूं।
एंड लाइक आई एम ओपनिंग वि नोटपड प्लस
प्लस। लेट्स सी जस्ट वंस। कुछ इस तरीके की
फाइल मिलती है। इसी फाइल में यहां पे
एंट्री करनी होती है। अब ये तो सारे
कमेंटेड हैं। तो दीज़ आर नॉट एक्चुअली
ऑपरेटिंग। बट जैसे यहां पे फॉर एग्जांपल
यहां पे दिया है x.com rino.com इसके
अगेंस्ट IP एड्रेसेस है। अब जब इस डोमेन
को ओपन करेंगे तो ये आईपीस को ये
कॉरेस्पोंड कर रहा है इस आईपी को। अब मैं
यहीं पे अगर एक एंट्री बना दूं यहां पे एक
एंट्री सॉरी यहां पे मैं एक एंट्री लिख
दूं।
मैं यहां पे एक हैश देके एंट्री मार दूं।
मान लो इस आई मान लो एक IP दे दूं। अ
127.0.1
और यहां पे एक डोमेन दे दूं। डोमेन दे दूं
fake वेबसाइट.com
एंड यहां पे एक कमेंट यहां पे लिख देता
हूं कि भैया ये किस चीज के लिए है?
फिशिंग आईपी तो इसका मतलब है कि ये जो
वेबसाइट है मैं ओपन करूंगा ना फेक
वेबसाइट.com तो ये इस पर्टिकुलर आईपी पे
रीडायरेक्ट हो जाएगी। और यह आईपी एक अटैकर
की हैकर की आईपी है जो मलेशियस कंटेंट को
होस्ट करता है। मैलवेज को होस्ट करता है
एंड वहां पे या फेक लॉगिनस आपको प्रोवाइड
करेगा। जैसे ही लॉग इन करेंगे दैट्स खत्म
कहानी वहीं पर वहीं पर कहानी खत्म हो जाती
है। एंड यू आर द नाउ विक्टिम ऑफ अ फिशिंग
अटैक। तो दिस इज कॉल्ड होस्ट फाइल
मॉडिफिकेशन अटैक। एज सिंपल एज दैट। गॉट
इट? हां जी। लाइक कर दिया करना। लाइक सब
भी कर दिया करो यार। लाइक ठोका करो। लाइक
करने में क्या ही कंजूसी करनी है।
अब यहां पे एसओसी डिटेक्शन इंडिकेटर में
क्या आते हैं?
सडन डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड चेंज डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड
के अंदर में सडन कोई चेंज हो रहा है वह
आपको नोटिस करनी है। डीएनएस रिस्पांस कुछ
गड़बड़ डीएनएस रिस्पांस आ रही है। वो आपको
नोटिस करना है। अब इसके लिए मैं आपको
टास्क पहले ही दे चुका हूं कि डीएनएस के
बारे में आपको पढ़ना है। मैं आपको पहले ही
बोल चुका हूं कि यहां पे
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग एंड डीएनएस के बारे में
आपको थोड़ी जानकारी लेनी है। यह आपका
टास्क है। उसकी जानकारी के बारे में पढ़
के एक्सप्लोर करना है। एंड Lindin पे डाल
के हमें टैग करना है डिफ्रॉनिक्स को।
इंटरनल डीएनएस एनोमेलिस डीएनएस के अंदर
कोई किसी तरह की कोई आपको गड़बड़ी या किसी
तरह की कोई अ इंडिकेशन लग रहे हैं, कुछ
डाउट लग रहा है वो मल्टीपल यूज़र्स
रिवॉल्विंग सेम रिॉल्विंग सेम डोमेन टू
अनयूजुअल आईपीस। बहुत सारे यूज़र्स हैं एक
ही डोमेन को मल्टीपल अलग-अलग एक अनयूजुअल
आईपीस जो आपको लगे कि अरे यार अजीब ये
आईपी पे रिज़ॉल्व होना नहीं चाहिए। ऐसी
डोमेनस को हो रहा है तो भी आपका ये एक
इंडिकेटर जो है यह आपके लिए जरूरी है।
होस्ट फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन अलॉट्स मतलब होस्ट
फाइल को मॉडिफाई की गई है। तो आपके एसओसी
में अलॉट इसका आएगा कि भैया होस्ट फाइल को
कुछ मॉडिफाई तो किया गया है। जल्दी से
इसके ऊपर देखो क्या हो रहा है। सर्टिफिकेट
मिसमैच एरर्स सर्टिफिकेट्स मिसमैच हो रहे
हैं। डोमेनस अगर कोई डोमेन आप ओपन कर रहे
हैं उसके सर्टिफिकेट्स का मिसमैच कुछ आ
रहा है। कुछ एरर आ रही है तो उसको भी आपको
मॉनिटर करना होता है। तो ये सारी चीजें जो
हैं आप करेंगे एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन
इंडिकेटर्स में आपको ये चीजें देखनी होती
है जब डीएनएस पोइजनिंग जो जब ये डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग अटैक है जो कि फार्मिंग का ही एक
पार्ट है फार्मिंग का ही एक तरीका है तो
आपको ये सब चीजें देखनी है एसोसिएट
सिनेरियो में कैसा आएगा अलॉट में क्या
आएगा मल्टीपल यूज़र्स एक्सेसिंग bankcom
रॉल्विंग टू फॉरेन आईपी अब मान लो मल्टीपल
यूज़र्स हैं जो bank को एक्सेस कर रहे हैं
बट उस एक्सेस को जब वो bank को ओपन कर रहे
हैं ना तो एक फॉरेन आईपी ओपन हो रही है ये
कौन सी बात हो गई भाई इसका मतलब है dns के
साथ खिलवाड़ हुआ है। dns एग्जैक्टली जो
bank.com को एक्चुअल IP पे रिॉल्व करना
चाहिए वो एक्चुअल आईपी पे रिॉल्व नहीं कर
रहा। वो किसी एक फॉरेन बेकार की बाहर की
आईपी पे रिॉल्व कर रहा है। मतलब उस पे
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है। तो दिस इज़ डेंजरस।
तो ये एसओसी का एक अलॉट है। इन्वेस्टिगेशन
में क्या आएगा? डीएनएस के लॉ्स को चेक
कीजिए कि देखिए भैया कहां कौन सी आईपी पे
रिॉल्व क्या हुआ है। एग्जैक्टली नॉन
लेजिटमेट आईपी से कंपेयर कीजिए। जो भी
आपके पास लिस्ट है, डेटा है उससे कंपेयर
कीजिए। डीएनएस सर्वर कंप्रोमाइज हुआ है कि
नहीं इसको चेक आउट कीजिए एंड एंड पॉइंट्स
चेक एंड पॉइंट्स फॉर होस्ट फाइल टपरिंग
मतलब एंड पॉइंट्स मशीन यानी कि आपका
लैपटॉप सर्वर कंप्यूटर जो भी है उसमें चेक
कीजिए कि कोई होस्ट फाइल्स के अंदर में
कोई टपरिंग या किसी तरह की छेड़खानी तो
नहीं की गई है। तो ये एज अ एसोसिएशनलिस्ट
आपको इन चीजों का ध्यान रखना है। तो एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट आपको मल्टीपल चीजों का
ध्यान रखना पड़ता है। एक अटैक के अगेंस्ट
आपको देयर आर डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ़ थिंग्स
दैट यू शुड बी कंसीडरिंग दैट यू शुड बी
अटेंशन अबाउट
दोस काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स। तो, यह चीजें मेनली
मैटर करती है। राइट? थैंक यू ब्रदर। थैंक
यू मी। थैंक यू। 225 लाइक कर दिया। क्या
बात है यार।
तो, दिस इज़ द एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन
इंडिकेटर्स। ये आपको समझ में आया? एसोसिएट
डिटेक्शन इंडिकेटर्स? आर यू गेटिंग व्हाट
आई एम ट्राइंग टू से?
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस?
बताइए मुझे। आर यू गेटिंग?
जल्दी बताइए
एवरीवन प्लीज आंसर आई एम सेइंग योर आंसर्स
ओके
चलिए काफी लोगों को समझ में आ रहा है।
अच्छी बात है।
गुड। बढ़िया है।
ओके चलिए तो एज आई सी काफी लोगों को समझ
में आ रहा है प्रैक्टिकल भी पढ़ते हैं कुछ
प्रैक्टिकल भी पढ़ेंगे भाई पढ़ेंगे पढ़ेंगे
प्रैक्टिकल भी पढ़ेंगे देखो प्रैक्टिकल के
लिए आप लोग श्योर मत करो आप लोग ज्यादा
प्रैक्टिकल के लिए टेंशन मत लो जो चीज़ आनी
है वो तो आएंगी जो चीजें होनी है वो होंगी
जो चीजें पढ़नी है वो पढ़ेंगी जो चीज़ सीखनी
है सीखेंगी अब जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग है तो
उसमें जो चीजें रिक्वायरमेंट होगी वो तो
मैं कराऊंगा ही। तो उसको एक लाइन अप करके
कराएंगे ना। ऐसा थोड़ी ना कि प्रैक्टिकल
जो चीजें बाद में आनी है उसको पहले लेकर आ
जाऊं। फिर आपको समझ में नहीं आएगा। फिर आप
प्रैक्टिकल करके बस जॉब रेडी थोड़ी ना बन
जाओगे। तो इसको जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग की तरह
देखो। एक प्रैक्टिकल ओनली ट्रेनिंग की तरह
मत देखो। प्रैक्टिकल्स एंड जो चीजें आनी
है वो सब आएंगी। इसके लिए बेधड़क
टेंशन बिना टेंशन के रहो। ठीक है? बस मैं
इतना ही बोलूंगा।
मेरे डिनर की टाइम टेंशन मत लो भाई। मेरे
डिनर का अभी तो बाद में होगा। कभी भी हो
जाएगा।
2000 लाइक कर दो। 2000 लाइक कहां से होगा?
ठीक है? तो ये है एसओसी के डिटेक्शन के
इंडिकेटर्स। अब इसी में एक अटैक आता है
एविल ट्विन अटैक। मैं अटैक्स की पहले बता
दूं आज। फिर हम आगे कंटिन्यू करेंगे
नेक्स्ट सेशन में। अटैक्स के बारे में
पहले देखिए। एविल ट्विन अटैक। ये भी एक
तरह का फिशिंग अटैक है। जिसमें कि क्या
होता है? एन अटैकर क्रिएट्स अ फेक वाई-फाई
एक्सेस पॉइंट दैट लुक्स आइडेंटिकल टू अ
लेजिटमेट वन। जैसे कि रियल वाई-फाई का नाम
है कैफे वाई-फाई। एंड अटैकर ने एक वाई-फाई
बना दिया कैफे Wi-Fi फ्री। बस अब कोई
वाई-फाई अगर सेम ऑलमोस्ट नेम से आती है
फ्री मिलती है आपको बिना किसी सिक्योरिटी
के तो उससे ऑलमोस्ट आपके नॉर्मली आप उससे
कनेक्ट कर लेते हैं। अरे भाई हो सकता है
उन्हीं का एक फ्री वाला होगा। कनेक्ट कर
लो। अब कनेक्ट किया बस कहानी खत्म। क्या
होता है? एक है क्या होता है भैया? एक
हैकर है हमारा। एक हमारा इंटरनेट यूजर है।
ठीक है? अब यह एक लेजिटमेट वाई-फाई
हॉटस्पॉट से यहां पे कनेक्टेड है। सिंपल
सा ये सिक्योर है। इंटरनेट यूज़ कर रहा है।
बट यहीं पे इस बंदे ने हैकर ने एक एल
ट्विन नेटवर्क सेटअप कर लिया है। जहां पे
बेसिकली क्या कर रहा है? यह अब लेजिटमेट
हॉटस्पॉट से ना कनेक्ट करके एक एल ट्विन
नेटवर्क से कनेक्ट हो जा रहा है।
अनसिक्योर कनेक्शन के थ्रू इंटरनेट को
एक्सेस यहां पे इंटरनेट तक पहुंच रहा है।
बट इस नेटवर्क के थ्रू कनेक्ट होने के
कारण अब जो भी चीजें वो ब्राउज़ करेगा, जो
भी चीजें वो सर्व करेगा, जो भी चीजें वो
डेटा सेंड रिसीव करेगा, वो एक हैकर के
नेटवर्क के थ्रू जाएंगी। एंड वहां पे हैकर
उसको इंटरसेप्ट कर सकता है। तो यानी कि
अगर आप किसी वेबसाइट को ओपन कर रहे हैं,
वहां कोई लॉग इन क्रेडेंशियल्स डाल रहे
हैं, क्रेडिट कार्ड डिटेल्स डाल रहे हैं।
किसी भी तरह की प्राइवेट सेंसिटिव डिटेल्स
डाल रहे हैं, वो अटैकर को पता चल जाएगा।
दैट्स इट। कहानी खत्म हुई होगी। कहानी ओवर
ये होती है एविल टू विन अटैक। राइट।
हां। स्कैन क्यूआर टू कनेक्ट टू आवर फ्री
वाईफाई सर्विस। बिल्कुल सही।
हां जी। लाइक कितने लोगों ने ठोका भाई?
लाइक यार ज्यादा लाइक नहीं आई है क्या आज?
ऐसा क्या हो गया? क्यों नाराज हो यार?
इतना तो बताओ। लाइक्स ओनली 225। चलो अच्छी
बात है। इतना भी सही है लाइक बट आई थिंक
कि ज्यादा होने चाहिए। कम से कम 300 लाइक
होने चाहिए। मुझे देखता हूं मैं कि सेशन
खत्म होने तक 300 लाइक होते हैं कि नहीं।
पूरा कोर्स होगा। सब कुछ होगा। देखो भाई
ट्रेनिंग मैं पूरी लूंगा। पूरी सेशन भी
कराऊंगा। आपकी एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट
भी करूंगा। बट मैं आपको इस बात के लिए
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं। पहले से अभी फिर से
बोल रहा हूं कि ट्रेनिंग कितनी
जल्दी-जल्दी आएंगी। यह आपके दो फैक्टर्स
पर डिपेंड करता है। एक तो आप लाइव में आ
रहे हैं। कितने लोग प्रेजेंट रह रहे हैं।
पहले 350 थे, 300 हुए, 200 हुए, अभी 100
के ऊपर हैं। और दूसरी 250 कमेंट्स ऑन ईच
वीडियोस। जितने भी सेशंस होंगे उसमें 250
कमेंट्स नॉन रिपीटेड यूनिक कमेंट्स। मतलब
एक यूजर का एक ही कमेंट काउंट होगा। 250
कमेंट्स होने चाहिए। जैसे ही हो जाएंगे
आपके नेक्स्ट सेशन आ जाएंगे। जैसे ही आपने
250 लास्ट वीडियो पे करे और मैं आज इवन
वेडिंग फंक्शन में हूं। फिर भी मैं आपके
लिए क्लास लेकर आ रहा हूं। तो मैं अपनी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज यहां पर एग्जीक्यूट कर
रहा हूं। मैं अपनी प्रॉमिससेस पर रह रहा
हूं। आप तो रहो यार कम से कम कि एटलीस्ट
अटेंड तो कर लो। आपका जा क्या रहा है?
थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा। स्किल सीखने में लग रहा
है। कहीं फर्जी काम करने में तो नहीं लग
रहा। एज सिंपल एट दैट।
राइट?
हां। तो ये है एल ट्विन अटैक। हां। एल
ट्विन अटैक के थ्रू मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक
करा जा सकता है। जब आप किसी और नेटवर्क के
अंदर में कनेक्ट हो जाते हैं एक फर्जी
नेटवर्क में तो वहां से वो आपकी चीजों को
स्नैफ स्निफ कर सकता है। स्निफिंग कर सकता
है। मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक लॉन्च कर सकता
है। सो या मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक इज़ काइंड
ऑफ़ अ आउटकम ऑफ़ दिस एल ट्विन अटैक। सिंपल।
नोट्स भी बनाया कीजिए। याद रखिएगा। Lindin
पे पॉइंट्स डालिए। Lindin पे काफी कम लोग
अभी पॉइंट्स डाल रहे हैं। प्लीज आप लोग हर
डे के जो भी की पॉइंट्स हैं, जो भी आपने
सीखा, जो भी आपने जाना, उसको और जो टास्क
से रिलेटेड की पॉइंट्स है, उसको लिख के की
पॉइंट की तरह नोट डाउन करके Lindin पे
डालिए एंड हमें टैग कीजिए डिफ्रॉनिक्स को।
मैं मैं बार-बार बोल रहा हूं।
कोई बात नहीं। आप उसको कंटिन्यू कीजिए।
सर WhatsApp पे लड़के लड़की को मैसेज करते
हैं। इग्नोर कर दीजिए सिंपल। अब एल डन
अटैक कैसे काम करता है? अटैकर सेट्स अप अ
रॉग एक्सेस पॉइंट। अटैकर एक फेक एक्सेस
पॉइंट सेट अप करता है। विक्टिम उससे
कनेक्ट हो जाता है। अटैकर ट्रैफिक को
इंटरसेप्ट करता है। क्रेडेंशियल्स को
कैप्चर करता है। सेशन हाईजैकिंग करता है
अगर पॉसिबल हो पाए। तो यहीं पे जो ट्रैफिक
इंटरसेप्शन की बात आई। यहां पे हम इसको हम
बात करते हैं एमआईटीएम की। यहां पे हम
एमआईटीएम की बात करेंगे। जब वो इंटरसेप्ट
कर रहा है तो यहां पे मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक
की बात कर रहा है। यह हमेशा किस चीज के
लिए लीड करता है? एमआईटीएम मैन इन द मिडिल
अटैक क्रेडेंशियल थफ्ट्स आपकी डिटेल्स
आपके लॉगिन्स चुराना। कुकीज़ स्टीलिंग
कुकीज़ जिसमें कि सेंसिटिव इनेशन या लॉग इन
डिटेल्स भी जा सकते हैं। उनको चुराना फेक
कैप्टिव पोर्टल लॉग इन पेजेस जहां पे आपको
फेक लॉगिन पेजेस बनाने को देखने को
मिलेगा। जहां पे आप डिटेल्स डालेंगे और
आपको उस आपके डिटेल्स को कैप्चर कर लिया
जाएगा। तो यह एविल ट्वीन जो है यह इस
तरीके से काम करता है। अब यह डेंजरस क्यों
है? क्योंकि इट्स अ वेरी डेंजरस अटैक
क्योंकि इसमें कोई टेक्निकल एक्चुअली
स्किल की रिक्वायर्ड नहीं है। एक
सॉफ्टवेयर आएगा, एक टूल आएगा ल्च कीजिए।
एक फेक एक्सेस पॉइंट बन जाएगी फ्री का
वाई-फाई वाला और उससे कनेक्ट करके आप
दूसरे वाले के यूज़र्स की डिटेल्स ले सकते
हैं। एक ऑटोमेटेड मेड लॉगिन पोर्टल्स के
थ्रू। अब ये एयरपोर्ट्स पे ज्यादातर यूज़
किए जाते हैं विल ट्विन अटैक्स, होटल्स
में, कैफेज़ में, कॉन्फ्रेंसेस में। तो जब
आप किसी पब्लिक प्लेस पे हो, रेलवे
स्टेशंस पे हो, एयरपोर्ट्स पे हो, होटल्स
में हो, कैफेज़ में हो, कॉन्फ्रेंसेस में
हो, तो आपको अगर फ्री वाई-फाई वगैरह मिल
रहा है कहीं पे तो कनेक्ट करो। ठीक है
चलेगा। बट सेंसिटिव डिटेल्स और डाटा शेयर
मत किया करो उस पे। किसी भी तरह किसी भी
सेंसिटिव वेबसाइट्स में या Google में लॉग
इन करने लगे, Facebook में लॉग इन करने
लगे, Instagram पे लॉग इन करने लगे,
बैंक्स में लॉग इन करने लगे, ये सब मत
किया करो। हो सकता है ज्यादा चांसेस हैं
आपके डिटेल्स वहां पे चुरा लिए जाएंगे।
आपके डिटेल्स को कैप्चर कर लिया जाएगा।
एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन इंडिकेटर्स में क्या
होता है? इनसाइड कॉर्पोरेट एनवायरमेंट
अनअथराइज्ड एक्सेस पॉइंट डिटेक्टेड ऐसा
आता है कि अरे यार एक ऑथराइज एक्सेस पॉइंट
डिटेक्ट हुआ है। ऐसे अलॉट में आपको आएगा
इंडिकेटर्स में आपको आएगा। डुप्लीकेट एसएस
आईडी डिटेक्टेड एक मल्टीपल एसएस आईडी।
एसएसआईडी मतलब जो नाम आपके वाई-फाई का
होता है ना वही एसएस आईडी कहलाता है। आपने
कुछ भी जो भी नाम रखा उसको एसएस आईडी
बोलते हैं। तो डुप्लीकेट मतलब मल्टीपल
एसएस आईडी यहां पे आपको मिल रहे हैं। तो
ये डिटेक्शन हो गई। एआरपी स्पूफिंग अलर्ट।
एआरपी पोइजनिंग हो रही है। एड्रेस
रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल की पोइजनिंग हो रही
है। जिसके थ्रू धमाका हो रहा है। तो उसका
अलर्ट आ जाएगा। अनयूजुअल डीएचसीपी सर्वर
डिटेक्टेड। एक ऐसा डीएससीपी सर्वर।
डीएससीपी मतलब वही होता है ना जो आईपीस को
एलोकेट करता है ऑटोमेटिकली। वो मल्टीपल
डीएससीपी सर्वर्स को डिटेक्ट किया जा रहा
है। नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक को इंटरसेप्ट किया जा
रहा है। इस तरीके की चीजें हो तो ये
इंडिकेटर्स डिफाइन करती है कि भैया यहां
पे इविल टू एन अटैक्स जैसी कोई चीज हो रही
है। अब एंटरप्राइज एसोसिएट टीम्स क्या
करते हैं? यूज़ करते हैं। विड्स को यूज़
करते हैं। वायरलेस आईडीएस एक होती है
इंट्रोसन डिटेक्शन सिस्टम। विड्स का मतलब
होता है वायरलेस आईडीएस। एक वायरलेस
इंट्रोसेंट डिटेक्शन सिस्टम को यूज़ करती
है। एनएससी को यूज़ करती है। नेटवर्क
एक्सेस कंट्रोल जहां पे एक्सेस कंट्रोल्स
की अलग-अलग तरह के रूल्स पे ये ऑपरेट करते
हैं। एंड सर्टिफिकेट बेस्ड वाई-फाई ऑर्थ
जो कि एक सर्टिफिकेट बेस पे काम करती है।
एंड इस तरीके की टीम्स चीजें जो है
सिक्योरिटी के लिए काम में ली जाती है
कॉर्पोरेट एंटरप्राइज एसओसी टीम्स के
द्वारा। इस तरीके से यह डेंजरस होता है।
अब इसी का इसी चीजों को फिशिंग जैसे
अटैक्स को जिसे फिशिंग के हमने मल्टीपल
चीजें देखे। ठीक है? तो हमने पहले सबसे
पहले देखो हमने आज सबसे पहले क्या देखा?
फिशिंग क्या होता है? उसके बाद हमने
फिशिंग के अलग-अलग टाइप्स देखे जिसमें हम
ईमेल फिशिंग हमने देखा। स्पेयर फिशिंग
क्या होता है? वेलिंग क्या होता है?
स्मिशिंग क्या होता है? विशिंग क्या होता
है? फार्मिंग क्या होता है? फार्मिंग के
अंदर फिर हमने डीएनएस पोइजनिंग देखा।
होस्ट फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन देखा। देन एसओसी
डिटेक्शन इंडिकेटर्स में किस तरीके से ये
चीजें आती हैं। किस तरीके से डिटेक्ट होती
है, अलर्ट आती है वो देखा। देन हमने
फिशिंग का ही एक पार्ट एविल ट्वीन अटैक
देखा। देन हमने एिल ट्विन कैसे वर्क करता
है वो देखा। देन क्यों ये डेंजरस है?
इंडिकेटर्स क्या होते हैं वो देखा। ये
सारी चीजें देखी हमने। अब इसी में हम इन
चीजों को किस तरीके से एग्जीक्यूट करते
हैं? इन चीजों को एग्जीक्यूट हम करते हैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स के थ्रू। सिंपल
सा फंडा है। हम इन चीजों को सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक के थ्रू एग्जीक्यूट करते
हैं। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक का मतलब है
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इज़ इक्वल टू साइकोलॉजिकल
मैनपुलेशन टू ट्रिक पीपल। ये एक ऐसा
मैनपुलेशन है जो साइकोलॉजिकल मैनपुलेशन
जहां लोगों को आप ट्रिक कर देते हैं।
लोगों को आप बेवकूफ बना देते हैं। किस चीज
के लिए? सेंसिटिव इनेशन को रिवील करने के
लिए। एक्सेस को ग्रांट करने के लिए,
सिक्योरिटी ब्रेकिंग एक्शंस को परफॉर्म
करने के लिए। मैल्वस को इंस्टॉल करने के
लिए एंड पैसे ट्रांसफर करने के लिए। इट
एक्सप्लइट्स ह्यूमन वनेबिलिटीज नॉट
टेक्निकल वलेबिलिटीज़। एंड ह्यूमन
वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट करना सबसे बड़ा
एक्सप्लइट माना जाता है। सबसे
बिगेस्ट लेवल का एक अटैक माना जाता है।
जिसकी काउंटर मेजर ऑलमोस्ट नेगिजिबल है।
इसको आप काउंटर मेजर इसका काउंटर मेजर कुछ
है ही नहीं। जहां आप ह्यूमन के ह्यूमन पे
अटैक कर रहे हैं। ह्यूमन के इमोशंस को
एक्सप्लइट कर रहे हैं। ह्यूमन वेलेबिलिटीज
को एक्सप्लइट कर रहे हैं। सो ये सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कहलाता है। जिसमें कि आप
सामने वाले बंदे के इमोशंस के साथ खेल रहे
हैं। उसके माइंड के साथ खेल रहे हैं और
उससे ही चीजों को लेकर आ रहे हैं। इनफेशन
निकलवा रहे हैं। इसको हम ओवरऑल सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कहते हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
आप सब में कई लोगों ने दृश्य मूवी देखी
होगी। आई डोंट नो कि यू हैव सीन ऑ नॉट।
ठीक है? बताइए मुझे।
हैव यू सीन
दृश्यम मूवी दृश्यम वन या टू
आप लोगों ने देखा
अगर आपने दृश्यम मूवी देखी होगी तो अच्छी
बात है नहीं देखी तो प्लीज देखिएगा दृश्यम
फर्स्ट एंड टू उसमें सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का
बहुत बड़ा एग्जांपल सेट है कैसे मॉडिफाई
एंड माइंड को मैनपुलेट किया जाता है कि
मैं 2 अक्टूबर को
गोवा के पंजी में सत्संग में गया था
हर बंदे को यही सेम बात बोलना बंदे को
मैनपुलेट कर देना। सब बंदे को लग रहा है
हां यह तो भाई दो तारीख को
गोवा के पंजी में सत्संग में थे। बताइए।
सो दिस इज अ काइंड ऑफ़ मैनपुलेशन। जहां पे
आप एक ही चीज को रिपीटेड मोड में करके
उसको माइंड में सेट कर देते हो लोगों के
या ऐसी चीजें बताते हो, बोलते हो जो सामने
वाला खुद आपको उसकी जो है वो इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल के देता है।
राइट?
दिस इज़ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। अब सिसल
इंजीनियरिंग में साइकोलॉजिकल अटैक्स कोर
साइकोलॉजिकल अटैक्स क्या होते हैं? एक
ऑथॉरिटी होती है, अर्जेंसी होती है, फियर
होता है, देन स्केसिटी होती है,
रेसिप्रोसिटी होती है, फमिलियरिटी एंड
ट्रस्ट होता है। अब ऑथर ऑथॉरिटी मतलब कि
जो पीपल जो लोग होते हैं वो ऑथॉरिटी को
सलाम करते हैं। कोई बड़े लेवल का अधिकारी,
कोई बड़े लेवल का ऑफिसर होगा तो उसको
बोलते हैं जय श्री राम, जय ऐसे करके और
उसको सलाम बोलते हैं कि भैया सलाम। आप तो
बड़े लेवल के अधिकारी हैं। आपसे क्या ही
बहस करें? सो अब मान लो एग्जांपल दिस इज
आईटी डिपार्टमेंट शेयर योर पासवर्ड फॉर
सिस्टम मेंटेनेंस। अब ऐसे कोई बोलेगा कि
भैया आईटी डिपार्टमेंट से हम बोल रहे हैं
अपना पासवर्ड शेयर कीजिए। सिस्टम के
मेंटेनेंस को सिस्टम मेंटेनेंस स्टार्ट
करना है। तो सामने वाला घबरा जाएगा। अरे
भाई इतनी बड़ी अथॉरिटी से आया हुआ है
रिक्वेस्ट। जल्दी दे दो। ये होती है
ऑथॉरिटी। अर्जेंसी एकदम जल्दीबाजी में
लाना। रिमूव्स लॉजिकल थिंकिंग। अब इतनी
अर्जेंसी योर अकाउंट विल बी डिलीटेड इन 10
मिनट्स डू दिस। अब विक्टिम जो है वो
पैनिकिक कर जाएगा। विक्टिम पगला जाएगा।
दिमाग उसका खराब हो जाएगा। अरे भाई इतनी
जल्दी 10 मिनट में कौन अरे अरे क्या हुआ?
क्या करना है? जल्दी बताओ। अब वो लॉजिक ही
नहीं लॉजिक उसका उसके दिमाग में लॉजिक
बिल्डिंग होगी नहीं। उसके दिमाग उसका
दिमाग लॉजिकल काम करेगा ही नहीं। लॉजिकल
समझेगा ही नहीं कुछ। अर्जेंसी में वो क्या
करेगा? डिटेल्स दे देगा। चीजों को रिवील
कर देगा। फियर डर इनकम टैक्स नोटिस अटैच।
अरे इनकम टैक्स नोटिस आ गया। भले मेरी
कमाई ₹2 की हो लेकिन इनकम टैक्स की नोटिस
आ गई है। अब टेंशन में दिमाग खराब है। ₹2
कमा रहा हूं यार। इनकम टैक्स की नोटिस आ
गई है। बड़ा डर खौफ में आ जाता है इंसान।
तो इसका फायदा उठाना यह फियर होता है।
स्कैसिटी ओनली टू बोनस स्लॉट्स रिमेनिंग
ओनली टू सुपर डुपर कूपंस अवेलेबल फॉर
ग्रैंड फिनाले। अब ये स्केसिटी अरे कम हो
गई। खत्म हो गई। अब तो भाई ये खत्म होने
वाला है। अब इसको जल्दी खरीद लो क्योंकि
ये खत्म हो जाएगी। स्केसिटी पैदा करना।
रेसिप्रोसिटी आई हेल्प यू लास्ट वीक। कैन
यू सेंड मी दिस डॉक्यूमेंट? अपनी बड़प्पन
दिखाना। अरे लास्ट टाइम मैंने यार
तुम्हारी हेल्प करी थी।
जल्दी सामने सोचेगा अरे अरे हां यार भाई
ने हेल्प करी थी यार कुछ तो इसकी इसकी
हेल्प की हो कुछ तो रिप्लाई करना पड़ा
हमें हमारे ऊपर डेप्थ है यार उसके आई ओ
देम आई हैव टू गिव बैक देम तो
रेसिप्रोसिटी दिखाना ये कहते हैं
फमिलियरिटी एंड ट्रस्ट मतलब इंपपर्सनेट
कॉल कोग्स यूज़ इंटरनल लैंग्वेज रेफरेंसेस
रियल प्रोजेक्ट्स मतलब कि यहां पे कोलीग्स
का इंपर्सनेशन करना कोई भाई दोस्त यार
ऑफिस ऑफिस जिसके दोस्त हैं ये सब है उनकी
उनको इंपर्सनेट करना उन्हीं की तरह बात
करना उन्हीं की तरह आपको बातें आपसे चीजें
निकलवाने की कोशिश करना तो आप सोचो अरे
यार कलीग है ये है वो है ठीक है दे दो यार
इंटरनल लैंग्वेज
ठीक है अरे कोई इंटरनल लैंग्वेज अरे भाई
कैसे हो हां ठीक है अरे अरे आप भी वहीं से
हो क्या हां अरे हम भी वहीं से हैं चलो
भाई बताओ यार ये क्या है भाई तो ये मजा
आता है सामने वाले को राइट
मैं मल्टीपल अरे भाई सेम लैंग्वेज में ऐसे
करके कि होया भाई ऐसे मतलब कोई पंजाब में
है तो पंजाबी बोलेगा कोई ऐसे भोजपुरी टाइप
बोल देगा हरियाणवी टाइप बोल देगा
राजस्थानी टाइप बोल देगा इस टाइप सी चीजें
तो कोई हरियाणा शहर हरियाणवी ऐसे बात कर
ले ऐसे कुछ कहते हैं तो ये चीजें थोड़ी सी
फमिलियरिटी ट्रस्ट को बिल्ड अप करती है
जिसके थ्रू इंफॉर्मेशन निकाला जा सकता है।
अब सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के भी अलग-अलग टाइप्स
होते हैं। देखो इसमें जैसे मल्टीपल टाइप्स
आते हैं। ठीक है? जैसे प्रीटेक्स्टिंग आती
है, बेटिंग आता है, वाटरिंग होल अटैक आता
है। यह सारी चीज़ें आती हैं जो कि किसके
होते हैं? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के टाइप्स
होते हैं। अब इसमें प्रीक्स्टिंग
के अंदर में मल्टीपल अटैक्स होते हैं।
जिसमें इंपॉर्शनेशन आता है, टेल गेटिंग
आता है, पिगी बैंकिंग आता है, बेटिंग आता
है, फिशिंग आती है, विशिंग आती है,
स्केयरवेयर आता है। जैसे मैंने फिशिंग,
विशिंग ये सब तो बताया आपको सब चीजें। बट
इसी के अलग-अलग टाइप्स आते हैं। अब इन
टाइप्स के बारे में बहुत डिटेल में आपको
खुद से एक्सप्लोर थोड़ी करनी पड़ेगी
क्योंकि ये एक्सप्लोर आप करेंगे तो आपको
आईडिया लगेगा। इन चीजों की वैसे कोई बहुत
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है क्योंकि ये फिशिंग
मतलब सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के बस टाइप्स हैं।
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का एक मतलब होता है कि
मैनपुलेट करना। मैनपुलेट करके इनेशन
निकालना। ह्यूमन के साइकोलॉजिकल जो
मैनपुलेशन है उसको एग्जीक्यूट करना।
साइकोलॉजिकल जो भी चीजें हो रही हैं उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करके उसको मैनपुलेट करके
एग्जीक्यूट करके डिटेल्स को निकालना। बस
यही एक होता है हमारे सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक का मतलब। अब इसी में अलग-अलग चीजें
बना दी गई है कि भैया एक प्रिटेक्स्टिंग
होता है, एक वेटिंग होता है भैया एक हमारा
एक
टेलगेटिंग होता है। ये सब चीजें होती है।
तो ये बस टाइप्स हैं जिनको आपको समझना है।
दैट्स इट। और कुछ भी नहीं है। नथिंग एट
ऑल। अब जैसे मान लो प्रीटेक्स्टिंग का
मतलब है अटैकर क्रिएट्स अ फेक सिनेरियो
प्रीटेक्स्ट टू गेन एट ट्रस्ट। जैसे हाय
आई एम फ्रॉम आईटी। वी आर अपग्रेडिंग
वीपीए। प्लीज कंफर्म योर क्रेडेंशियल्स।
दिस इज़ प्लंड एंड रिसर्च। तो ये अरे भाई
भैया मैं तो एक आईटी से हूं। हम वीपीए
अपग्रेड कर रहे हैं। तो जल्दी अपना
डिटेल्स बताओ। अब ये प्रीटेक्स्टिंग
अस्यूम करना। एक खुद एक माहौल बना देना।
प्रीटेक्स्टिंग हो गया। वेटिंग अटैकर्स ऑफ
अस समथिंग टेंपटिंग। कुछ टेंपटिंग दे रहे
हैं। अभी एक USB ड्राइव अरे भाई यह USB
एक पेनड्राइव है। इसमें सैलरी के डाटा है
सारा जल्दी से देख के मुझे बता दो। आप तुम
अपना भी नाम देख लेना कहीं सैलरी डाटा में
कुछ आ रहा है इंक्रीमेंट वगैरह का। अरे
भाई इसमें क्रैक सॉफ्टवेयर है यार। लाखों
रुपए के सॉफ्टवेयर दे रहा हूं फ्री में
USB में। अरे USB ले लो। इसमें सॉफ्टवेयर
डाउनलोड करके दे रहा हूं। ऐसे बहुत लोग
करते हैं पता है ना? आज भी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी वाले हैं बहुत सारे।
पेनड्राइव में फ्री के सॉफ्टवेयर देने के
नाम पे कुछ भी डाल देते हैं। यूज़र्स के
कंप्यूटर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज करते हैं। पीछे
बैकग्राउंड में आके पीछे से पागल बनाते
हैं। इसको वेटिंग कहते हैं। वेटिंग सोशल
इंजीनियर अटैक होता है। अरे मूवी ये
डाउनलोड कर लो भाई पीछे में बस तुम अपना
एक्सेस दे दो। तो क्या होते हैं?
क्यूरसिटी मतलब आपको एक क्यूरसिटी होगी कि
भैया यू विल बिकम अ क्यूरियस फॉर एवरीथिंग
फॉर दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग। अरे बाप रे क्रैक
सॉफ्टवेयर। सैलरी डाटा सैलरी इंक्रीमेंट
होगी और ग्रीड लालच भी होगा आपके अंदर
उसके बाद कॉम्प्रोमाइज होगा सिंपल जहां पे
क्यूरियसिटी होगी जहां पर ग्रीड होगा वहां
लालच जहां लालच और जहां पे बहुत ज्यादा
एक्साइटमेंट होगी वहां कॉम्प्रोमाइज होना
ही होता है सिंपल सा बात
सिंपल
समझ में आ गया
आर यू गेटिंग
आर यू वेटिंग गाइस
प्लीज बताइए।
ओके दिस इज़ कॉल्ड बेटिंग।
अब इसी में आता है एक वाटरिंग होल अटैक
जिस जिसमें अलग-अलग तरह के अटैक्स को यूज़
जैसे एचटीएमl इंजेक्शन टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक्स को
भी यूज़ किया जाता है। अटैकर कॉम्प्रोमाइजज़
अ वेबसाइट फ्रीक्वेंटली विजिटेड बाय
टारगेट ग्रुप। अब कोई मान लो कोई
गवर्नमेंट के एंप्लाइज़ है वो रेगुलर एक
वेबसाइट को विजिट करते हैं। बार-बार विजिट
करते हैं। और ट्रैकर क्या करेगा? उसके ही
सर्वर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज या उस वेबसाइट को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेगा और उसमें मैलवेयर को
इंजेक्ट कर देगा। अब जैसे ही वो बंदे या
जो भी एंप्लाइजज़ या जो भी ग्रुप ऑफ़ पीपल
है उसको विजिट करेंगे वो एक्चुअली मैलवर्स
को डाउनलोड कर रहे हैं। दे आर डाउनलोडिंग
द मैलवर्स। तो इस तरह के भी अटैक्स होते
हैं। दिस काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स आर देयर। दिस
दिस इज़ कॉल्ड वाटरिंग होल अटैक। इसमें
क्या होता है? पहले में अटैकर सर्वर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके या वेबसाइट को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके एक्सप्लइट कोड को
इंस्टॉल कर लेता है। पहले स्टेप में।
दूसरे स्टेट में यूजर उस इनफेक्टेड सर्वर
या वेबसाइट मतलब इनफेक्टेड वेबसाइट को
विजिट करता है। उसके बाद जैसे ही वह विजिट
करता है वो एक्सप्लइट को एग्जीक्यूट करता
है। कोई भी चीज डाउनलोड करता है। वहां पे
एक ड्रॉपर कोड डाउनलोड वो कर लेता है। देन
वहां पे क्या होती है? ड्रॉपर डाउनलोड्स द
ट्रोजन कोड। उस वो ड्रॉपर ट्रोजन को
डाउनलोड कर लेता है। ट्रोजंस के कोड को
डाउनलोड करता है। उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर देता
है। यूज़र्स जो है अपने बैंक
वेबसाइट्स जो भी बैंक की वेबसाइट से या जो
भी उसको क्रेडिट जहां पे उसको ट्रांजैक्शन
या जो भी डिटेल्स वगैरह डाल के और अपना
एक्सेस करना होता है अकाउंट उसको विजिट
करता है और वहां पे क्रेडेंशियल्स को
डालता है। यूजरनेम पासवर्ड्स या क्रेडिट
कार्ड डिटेल जो भी है डालता है और उसके
क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुरा लिए जाते हैं और उस
क्रेडेंशियल्स को देन रेपोजिटरी को भेज
दिया जाता है। जो भी सर्वर का हैकर का या
अटैकर का रेपोज़िटरी है जहां पे सारी
क्रेडेंशियल्स को स्टोर करता है उसको भेज
दिया जाता है। क्रेडेंशियल्स स्टोर कर लिए
जाते हैं। अटैकर्स जो है सेव्ड
क्रेडेंशियल्स जो है उनको फिर यूज़ करता
है। सारे क्रेडेंशियल्स को स्टोर करता है।
सेव कर लेता है। तो ये टाइप को हम वाटरिंग
होल अटैक कहते हैं। बस सिंपल।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। अब सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का
लाइफ लाइफ साइकिल क्या होता है अटैक का?
पहले रिकॉनसेंस होती है। फिर रिलेशनशिप
बिल्डिंग होती है। देन एक्सप्लइटेशन होता
है। देन बाहर खत्म। रिक्नेसेंस में जैसे
इनेशन गैदर करना सामने वाले विक्टिम का।
देन उस विक्टिम से रिलेशनशिप एक बनाना।
फोन कॉल के थ्रू ईमेल्स के थ्रू या
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट काइंड एसएमएस के थ्रू
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट या इनफिजिकल बनके उसको
रिलेशनशिप डेवलप करना। देन उस रिलेशनशिप
के बाद उसकी वीकनेसेस को पता करना। उसकी
कमजोरियां पता करना एंड उसको एक्सप्लइट
करके क्रेडेंशियल्स सेंसिटिव डेटा चुराना।
फाइल या कोई एक मलिशस फाइल्स को
एग्जीक्यूट करना एंड एक्सेस ग्रांट लेना
जहां पे उसको एक्सेस नहीं मिलना चाहिए था
या उसका एक्सेस का कोई अधिकार नहीं है
उसको एक्सेस कर लेना एंड देन जो है अपने
ट्रेसेस को डिलीट कर देना एंड टेक्निकल
अटैक्स उसके बाद अलग-अलग तरह के अटैक्स को
स्टार्ट कर देना ये एक पूरा लाइफ साइकिल
है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स का दिस इज़ द
लाइफ साइकिल अब एसओसी का पर्सपेक्टिव क्या
होता है आप सस्िशियस लॉग इन आफ्टर फिशिंग
देखते हैं ईमेल वीपीए लॉग इन फ्रॉम न्यू
लोकेशनेशंस देखते हैं नए-नए लोकेशन से
वीपीए लॉग इन हो रही है। ईमेल फॉरवर्डिंग
रूल्स क्रिएट किए जा रहे हैं कि भैया यह
ईमेल को वहां फॉरवर्ड कर दो। इस ईमेल के
डेटा को वहां फॉरवर्ड कर दो। मतलब इनकमिंग
मेल को मल्टीपल एक्टर मल्टीपल फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन को रिसेट करने की रिक्वेस्ट्स
बार-बार आएंगी आपको। पासवर्ड रीसेंट
अटेमप्ट्स बार-बार आपको मिलेंगे और
इंपॉसिबल ट्रैवल लॉग इन जहां पर मतलब
कहीं-कहीं से आपको लॉगिनस के आपको दिखेंगे
कि अरे भैया एक ऐसी लोकेशन से लॉग इन हुई
है जहां पे कोई आपका एंप्लई या कोई
क्लाइंट ही नहीं है वहां से भी लॉग इन हो
रहा है। तो ये सब जो है इंडिकेशंस हैं जो
एसओसी की तरह एल1 की तरह आपको देखने
चाहिए। जब भी एक्टिविटीज होती हैं, इन
एक्टिविटीज को आपको नोट करना चाहिए कि
सस्िशियस लॉग इन हो रही है कोई। वीपीएल
लॉग इन अलग-अलग लोकेशन से हो रहे हैं।
ईमेल फॉरवर्डिंग के रूल्स कि मतलब इस ईमेल
के इनबॉक्स कंटेंट को कहीं और फॉरवर्ड कर
दो सस्िशियस हो सकता है। बार-बार
मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन या पासवर्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन को रिसेट करने का ऑप्शन आपको
मतलब बार-बार आपके आ रहा है। अलर्ट आ रहा
है और ट्रेवल लॉगिस अलग-अलग तरीके से आ
रही है। इंडियन कॉन्टेक्स्ट की अगर बात
करें तो इंडिया में सोशल इंजीनियर टैक्स
में अलग-अलग तरीके की चीजें यूज़ होती
हैं। जैसे कि फेक जीएसटी के नोटिससेस जैसे
कि जीएसटी के नोटिसेस, फेक जीएसटी के
नोटिसेस भेजना होता है।
इनकम टैक्स के फेक मेल्स को भेजा जाता है।
मतलब फेक मेल्स इनकम टैक्स के तरफ से भेजा
जाता है। कूरियर डिलीवरी स्कैम्स जिसमें
कि सबसे ज्यादा डिजिटल अरेस्ट के केसेस
वगैरह आपको देखने को अभी रिसेंट में मिले
होंगे। काफी ज्यादा लोग इससे अवेयर भी हुए
हैं। काफी लोगों को इसके बारे में बताया
भी गया। फोन के कॉल ट्यून में जबरदस्ती
घुसाया गया था। ये सब चीजें भी की गई थी।
राइट? अ केवाईसी वेरिफिकेशन फ्रॉड होता
है। केवाईसी के नाम पे वेरीफाई करने के
नाम पे फ्रॉड किया जाता है। बैंक का ओटीपी
स्कैम होता है। जॉब स्कैम होता है। फेक
जॉब्स वगैरह ऑफर किए जाते हैं। ये सारी
चीजें की जाती है। अब मोस्ट मेनी एसोसिए
अलर्ट्स रिलेट्स टू क्रेडेंशियल
हार्वेस्टिंग। ओटीपी कॉम्प्रोमाइज अकाउंट
टेकओवर। अब इंडियन कॉन्टेक्स्ट की बात
करें तो ज्यादातर क्रेडेंशियल
हार्वेस्टिंग यूजरनेम पासवर्ड्स या
सिंसियर सीवियर प्राइवेट डेटा का चुराना
या सेंसिटिव डेटा का चुराना होता है।
ओटीपी के कॉम्प्रोमाइजिस के ऊपर में होती
है एंड अकाउंट टेकओवर्स वगैरह के केसेस
ज्यादा देखे जाते हैं। ऐसे अलर्ट्स को
ज्यादा फोकस में लिया जाता है इंडियन
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में। ठीक है? ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
इसको डिफेंड कैसे करती है? सबसे बड़ी चीज
है सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस की ट्रेनिंग देना।
सबसे बड़ी चीज सिंपल सा बात सबसे बड़ी चीज
है कि सिक्योरिटी
एक सेकंड रुक जाइए।
सबसे बड़ी चीज है सिक्योरिटी की अवेयरनेस
ट्रेनिंग देना। क्योंकि बिना अवेयरनेस के
कोई भी अटैक से बचा नहीं जा सकता। और सोशल
इंजीनियर अटैक से बचने का सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
सबसे बिगेस्ट एक तरीका है वो है
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस। अवेयरनेस नहीं होगी।
यू कैन नॉट डिफेंड सोशल इंजीनियर अटैक्स।
यू कैन नॉट बी सेफगार्ड फ्रॉम दिस काइंड
ऑफ़ अटैक्स। फिशिंग साइमुलेशन कैंपेन।
फिशिंग का सेमुलेशन करना। मतलब फिशिंग
जैसे होती है एक्सैक्टली अटैकर्स करते हैं
जिस टाइप से फिशिंग कैंपेन चलाते हैं।
वैसे ही एक वर्चुअल या एक फेक फिशिंग
कैंपेन को अपने खुद से कंपनी वाले स्टार्ट
करते हैं या कंपनी वाले ऐसे सर्विस खरीदते
हैं और अपने एंप्लाइजज़ को बताते हैं कि
भैया देखो ऐसे-ऐसे फिशिंग होती है। इस
तरीके से होती है। ट्रेनिंग देते हैं ताकि
ऐसा कोई अटैक हो तो उससे बचा जा सके
फ्यूचर में। ईमेल फिल्टरिंग। ईमेल में
अलग-अलग तरह के फिल्टर्स और अलग-अलग तरह
की रूल्स सिक्योरिटी डिफाइन करना। अलग-अलग
ईमेल सिक्योरिटी टूल्स आते हैं। उनके थ्रू
ताकि ईमेल्स जब आए तो बेसिकली फिल्टर हो
के आए ऐसी ईमेल्स और कोई भी फर्जी कोई भी
किसी भी तरह की ईमेल जो है आपके इनबॉक्स
में लैंड ना करें। मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
लगाना मतलब टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन, ओटीपी
बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन या ऑथेंटिकेटर एप्स
बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन या डिफरेंट मल्टीपल
ऑथेंटिकेशन बेस्ड सिस्टम्स को इनेबल करना
ताकि मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस हो। मल्टीपल तरीकों
से होके गुजरना पड़े अटैकर को एंड
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना उतना ही मुश्किल हो
जाए। अकाउंट्स या जो भी है डोमेन
मॉनिटरिंग डोमेन को मॉनिटर करते रहिए भैया
कि डोमेन में कोई छेड़खान तो नहीं हो रही।
डीएनएस पॉइंट जैसी चीजें तो नहीं हो रही
है। एंड ज़ीरो ट्रस्ट अप्रोच मतलब एक
नेटवर्क में कोई भी एंटर कर रहा है तो उस
पे ज़ीरो ट्रस्ट कोई भी ट्रस्ट मत कीजिए।
एक डिवाइस में एंटर हुआ है तो दूसरे
डिवाइस में जाने से पहले भी उसको
ऑथेंटिकेट करना पड़ेगा। ऐसा नहीं कि एक
नेटवर्क में एक डिवाइस में एंटर हो गया तो
सारे डिवाइसेस में एंटर कर सकता है। सामने
वाला बंदा या कोई भी कोई भी किसी भी तरह
का बंदा हो चाहे वो अटैकर हो चाहे वो
नॉर्मल यूजर हो। तो इसे जीरो ट्रस्ट बोलते
हैं। मतलब किसी पे ट्रस्ट मत करो। सबका
ऑथेंटिकेशन लगाओ। सब पे ऑथेंटिकेशन लगाओ।
हर पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट पे ऑथेंटिकेशन लगाओ।
हर एक नई एंट्री पे ऑथेंटिकेशन लगाओ। तो
ये जीरो ट्रस्ट अप्रोच होता है। तो ये
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स के बारे में ये
पूरी इंडियन कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात हुई। आई
होप कि आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। आर यू
गेटिंग गाइस? आर यू आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग?
आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग गाइस? मुझे बताइए।
गाइस आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग
समझ में आ गया? आई होप आपको समझ में आ गया
हो। राइट?
ओके। चलिए बहुत बढ़िया बात है। अच्छी बात
है। अगर आपको समझ में आ गया तो बहुत
बढ़िया बात है।
हम चलिए
ओके सो गाइस दैट्स इट फॉर टुडेेस सेशन आज
का सेशन मैंने बोला आपको बोला ही था कि आज
का सेशन मैं ज्यादा लंबा नहीं फिर भी 1.5
आवर्स का हो चुका है अ मतलब स्टिल इट्स
इट्स 1.5 आवर्स राइट नहीं कुछ होते-होते
भी इतना बड़ा बड़ा सेशन हो गया। सो आई होप
कि एंजॉयड द सेशन। राइट? यू आई यू एंजॉयड
द सेशन। हां। फिर भी 1.5 आवर्स तो हमने कर
ही लिया।
राइट?
चलिए। आई होप आप समझ गए होंगे इस चीज को।
आई होप आप आप आज के सेशन से समझे होंगे कि
बहाने तो आप में से कोई भी या मैं भी बना
सकता हूं। मैं आराम से चाहता हूं तो मैं
सेशन आज नहीं भी लेता तो क्या होता? लाइक
अगर मैं सेशन नहीं भी लेता तो क्या होता?
कुछ नहीं। नेक्स्ट सेशन जब लेता तो आप
आते। बिल्कुल। राइट? मतलब जब आप लेता तो
आप भी आते सेशन करने। बट मैंने आज सेशन
लिया क्योंकि मुझे एग्जैक्टली पता था कि
250 कमेंट्स हो चुके हैं ऑलरेडी वेबसाइट
लास्ट वीडियो पे। डे सिक्स की वीडियो पे
256 250 प्लस कमेंट्स हो चुके थे। मैंने
आपको प्रॉमिस किया था 250 प्लस कमेंट्स
करो। नया क्लास आ जाएगा। 250 कमेंट्स हर
वीडियो पे करो। एक यूनिक यूजर हर यूजर का
एक कमेंट होना चाहिए। ऐसा नहीं कि एक यूजर
10 कमेंट्स कर रहा है तो उसको काउंट नहीं
करेंगे। उसको एक ही कमेंट काउंट करेंगे और
जैसे ही 250 कमेंट हुआ आई विल ब्रिंग द
सेशन एंड लाइव में एटलीस्ट 100 प्लस रहा
करो एटलीस्ट हर सेशन में एंड आई विल
ब्रिंगिंग द क्लासेस। तो मैं अपनी
प्रॉमिससेस फुलफिल कर रहा हूं। आई होप कि
आप इसको सिंसियरली लेंगे और आप इस सेशन को
आगे बढ़वाएंगे। ये सेशंस ऐसी इस तरह की
सेशंस बढ़वाने का आगे का सिर्फ आप
रिस्पांसिबल हैं। आपके बेसिस पे ये सारा
कुछ होगा। अगर आप चाहेंगे तो ऐसे ही
कंटिन्यू रहेगा। जल्दी-जल्दी वीडियोस भी
आएंगी, क्लासेस भी आएंगी। आप नहीं चाहोगे
तो डिले भी होगा और क्लासेस भी आनी बंद हो
जाएंगी क्योंकि मैं आपके लिए अगर कुछ इतनी
टाइम निकाल रहा हूं इतना अपना डडीिकेशन दे
रहा हूं एंड ऐसी वेडिंग में आया हूं मैं
एक छुट्टियों में हूं मैं मेरे को मैं एक
ऑब्वियस सी बात है मेरे को एंजॉय करना
चाहिए इधर-उधर घूमना चाहिए बट मैं फिर भी
बीच में टाइम निकाल के 8:30 तक का मैंने
बोला था कि ऑलमोस्ट 8:30 तक का टाइम मैं
निकालूंगा एंड मैंने निकाला आपके लिए एंड
आई हैव डिलीवर द सेशन राइट तो आप इस चीज
को थोड़ा समझिए प्लीज और बीइंग अ स्टूडेंट
बीइंग अ लर्नर सिंसेनिस को समझ क्योंकि
बाद में ना आप फिर इन्हीं चीजों के पीछे
भागेंगे और कोई होगा नहीं आपको बताने के
लिए और यह यह वीडियो हो सकता है पेड हो
जाए मेंबर्स ओनली हो जाए पैसे देके आपको
देखने पड़े क्या फायदा हुआ तो आप आओ करो
एंड मैं आपको जॉब रेडी बनाऊंगा इस बात की
मैं आपको गारंटी लेता हूं मैं आपको मैं
आपको गारंटी के साथ बोलता हूं बस आप अपना
बेस्ट दो आप प्रेजेंट रहो और वीडियोस को
शेयर करो जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक दिया करो
सब्सक्राइब नहीं करा चैनल को सब्सक्राइब
कर दिया करो दैट्स इट और ग्रुप्स को वो
एसओसी का ग्रुप और WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो
कर लेना ठीक है? थैंक यू वेरी मच। ओके। लव
यू। लव यू गाइस।
ठीक है। आई होप एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड। सभी लोग
समझ गए? एक बार जल्दी से बता दीजिए। सभी
लोग जल्दी से चैट में सभी बताइए। तुरंत
बताइए ताकि मैं सेशन एंड करूं। एंड देन आई
एम गोइंग टू अटेंड द फंक्शन अगेन। ताकि
मैं भी निकलूं यार। कितने देर रोक के
रखोगे यार? थोड़ी तो वो करोगे कि दोस्त की
मतलब शादी है। दोस्त की वेडिंग फंक्शनंस
हैं। एंड तुम लोगों ने मुझे यहां रोक के
रखा हुआ है। बुरी बात है ना? ठीक है।
बताओ। एवरीवन गुड अंडरस्टैंड
थैंक्स ब्रदर थैंक्स नितीश
लव यू गाइस सो ओके सो ओके गाइस लव यू
एवरीबॉडी थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द
सेशन मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में बहुत
जल्द कमेंट्स जरूर कर देना जिनकाजिनका
कंप्लीट हो जाए रिकॉर्डिंग देखना कमेंट्स
मार देना 250 कमेंट्स होते ही फिर मिलते
हैं जल्दी से नेक्स्ट एसओसी के क्लास एट
में कुछ और भी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजों के ऊपर
और प्रैक्टिकल्स भी आएंगे यार टेंशन मत लो
प्रैक्टिकल टेंशन मत लो जो मैं पढ़ा रहा
हूं जैसे पढ़ा रहा हूं पढ़ते जाओ क्योंकि
तुम्हें यहां पे बस मैं एसओसी की कहानी
सुनाने नहीं आ रहा हूं मैं एक जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग डिलीवर कर रहा हूं। तो उसमें
जैसे-जैसे फ्लो आएगा, जिस तरीके से
टॉपिक्स जाएंगे, वैसे ही पढ़ाऊंगा। तो
पढ़ाने दो अपने अकॉर्डिंग, मेरे अकॉर्डिंग
एंड पढ़ते जाओ बस अपने अकॉर्डिंग सब मजा आ
जाएगा। ठीक है? ठीक है। ओके गाइस, थैंक्स।
बाय-ब गुड नाइट।